tensorflow is a widely popular framework
from google that helps to create machine
learning and deep learning models hello
everyone welcome to this full course
video on tensorflow today we have our
experienced instructors mohan and
richard who will take you through the
entire video in this video
you will first learn the basics of
tensorflow library and understand the
features of tensorflow
you will get an idea about tensors and
how tensorflow performs graphical
computations
you will learn how to install tensorflow
on ubuntu and implement machine learning
and deep learning models using python
then you will look at the difference
between tensorflow 1.2 versus 2.0
finally you will learn about tensorflow
object detection api
over to mohan now let's get started so
what is deep learning again this video
is not about deep learning but there are
other videos we have created in detail
about what is deep learning in this
video we'll just touch upon the basics
so that that's like a nice segue into
tensorflow so deep learning is um in a
way a subset of machine learning and we
use uh primarily neural networks in deep
learning and the underlying technology
behind artificial intelligence is deep
learning and here we teach them how to
recognize let's say images or voice and
so on and so forth so it is a learning
mechanism but here unlike traditional
machine learning the data is far more
complicated and far more unstructured
like it could be primarily in the form
of images or audio files or text files
and one of the core components of deep
learning is neural network and a neural
network somewhat looks like this there
is something known as an input layer and
then there is an output layer and in
between there are a bunch of hidden
layers so typically there would be at
least one hidden layer and anything more
than one hidden layer is known as a deep
neural network so any neural network
with more than three layers all together
right is known as a deep neural network
all right so what are the functions of
the various layers let's take a quick
look so the input layer accepts the
input so this could be in the form of
let's say if it is an image it could be
the pixel values of the images so that's
what the input layer does and then it
passes on to the hidden layers and the
hidden layers in turn perform certain
computations and they have what is known
as
as a part of the training they have
these weights and biases that they keep
updating till the training process is
complete and each neuron has multiple
weights and there will be one bias and
these are like variables and we will see
when we go into the tensorflow code what
we actually mean by that and so that's
what the hidden layer does it does a
bunch of computation and passes its
values to the output layer and then the
output layer in turn gives the output it
could be in the form of a class so for
example if we are doing classification
it tells us which class a particular
image maybe belongs to for example let's
say if this is a image classification
application then the input could be a
bunch of images of maybe cats and dogs
and the output will be like it will say
okay if this is activated this gives a
zero and this gives a one that means it
is a cat if this gives a one and this
gives a zero that means it is a dog so
that is a kind of a binary
classification and that can be extended
with multiple neurons on the output side
to have many more classes for example or
it can also be used for regression as
well not necessarily only classification
again since this video is not about
deep learning or machine learning or
neural network we will probably not go
into a lot of details but you can check
other videos where we have given a lot
more details about neural networks and
deep learning and so on so in order to
develop a deep learning application
how do you go about primarily there are
two or three components that are
required in order to develop deep
learning application you need obviously
a programming language so typically
python is used and that's what we are
going to use in this particular video
but you can also use other languages
like java or c plus plus and so on and
there are some libraries that are
readily available and for primarily for
doing
machine learning and deep learning
programming so these are a list of
libraries these are by no means the
exhaustive list but some of the most
common ones like keras theano tensorflow
and so on and so forth tensorflow has
nowadays become very very popular this
is developed by google and it is an open
source library and uh keras was there
before now keras has actually now become
a part of tensorflow as well so it is
one player about tensorflow so in that
sense they're well integrated so
combination of keras and uh tensorflow
is pretty good then of course you have a
torch and tl4j and so on and so forth so
there are multiple libraries but this
video is about tensorflow and we will be
focusing on tensorflow what are the
benefits of tensorflow and what are its
components and our towards the end we
will show you a code in python we've
written a code in python by the way
tensorflow can be used with multiple
languages it supports multiple languages
though python is by far the most popular
language so let's take a look at what
exactly is tensorflow and why we are so
excited about tensorflow so tensorflow
offers um apis now we can earlier
without when these libraries none of
these libraries were there even then we
were doing people were doing machine
learning and deep learning and so on but
the coding mechanism was much more
complicated what these libraries like
tensorflow offer is they provide kind of
a high level api so that we don't have
to go really deep into writing all the
stuff that is required let's say to
prepare a neural network and to even
configure or even uh to program a neuron
and so on right so these are done by the
library so all you need to do is they
offer a higher level api you need to use
that api and call that api and maybe
pass the data and that would pretty much
it's much easier rather than actually
going down and writing everything by
yourself so tensorflow that way it
offers apis for to write your code in
python or even c plus plus and so on
other languages java as well it has an
integration with r as well apparently
okay and it supports cpus as well as
gpus now deep learning applications are
very compute intensive especially the
training process needs a lot of
computation it takes very long as you
can imagine because the the data size is
large and there are so many iterative
processes there are so much of
mathematical calculations matrix
multiplication and so on and so forth so
for that if you perform these activities
on a normal cpu typically it would take
much longer but gpus are graphical
processing units you must have heard
gpus in the context of games and so on
because where you need the screen needs
to be of high resolution and the images
need to be of high resolution and so on
so gpus as the name such as graphical
processing unit were originally designed
for that but since they are very good at
handling this kind of iterative
calculations and so on now they are kind
of they are being used or leveraged
rather for doing or developing deep
learning applications and tensorflow
supports gpus as well as cpus so i think
that's one of the major advantages of
tensorflow as well now again what is
exactly tensorflow it's a open source
library developed by google and open
source and primarily for deep learning
development but tensorflow also supports
traditional machine learning by the way
so if you want to do some traditional
machine learning we can do it however it
is probably a bit of a overhead to use
tensorflow for doing traditional machine
learning and this is really good for
performing deep learning activities and
again if you want to get into more
details about what's the difference
between machine learning and deep
learning there is another video about it
you can probably take a look at that
video what else it is developed
originally for large numerical
computations so originally when
tensorflow was developed they never
thought of it as a keeping deep learning
in mind but ultimately it so happened
that it's really uh very good for deep
learning development and therefore
google has open sourced it and
tensorflow as the name suggests the data
is in the form of what is known as
tensors these are like multi-dimensional
arrays and they are very handy in
handling large amounts of data and we
will see that as well as we move forward
and then of course the execution
mechanism is in the form of graphs so
that makes it much easier to execute
this code in a distributed manner across
a cluster of computers and and also
using gpus and so on and so forth right
so that's a quick overview about what is
tensorflow we will see little bit more
detail the two major components that is
basically the tensors and the graphs
let's take a look at what they are so
what are tensors tensor is as i
mentioned earlier it is like a
multi-dimensional array in which the
data is stored now when we are doing
deep learning especially the training
process you will have large amounts of
data and the data is in typically in a
very complicated format and it really
helps when you are able to put this use
this or store it in a compact way and so
tensors actually offer a very nice and
compact way of storing the data handling
the data during computation this is not
really for storing on your hard disk or
things like that but in memory when
you're doing that computation tenses are
really really very handy in terms of
keeping the data compact because they
are like multi-dimensional arrays so the
data is stored in tensors and then it is
fed into the neural network and then you
get the output all right so there are
some terms associated with tensors let's
get ourselves familiarized one is uh the
dimension and another is the rank so
what is dimension typically dimension is
like the number of elements in a way so
for example this is a five by four
dimension tensor and then you can have
again the multi-dimensions right so you
can this can be like three by three by
three so that is uh the dimension and
then you have ranks so what are tensor
ranks ranks are basically traditionally
we would have thought of as dimensions
that is actually in this case it is
called rank so it becomes easier when we
see examples so a tensor's rank is
supposed to be zero when there is only
one element we also call this as scalar
so just one element and this is not
really a vector it's just an element
like 200 it's also known as a scalar so
such a tensor is supposed to be having a
rank of zero then you have let's say a
one dimensional array this is a vector
with a row of elements this has rank of
one now if you have traditionally what
we called as a two dimensional like a
matrix for example then the rank is two
and in this case the rank is three and
it can have more ranks as well as i
mentioned it is like a multi-dimensional
array so you can have rank five six and
so on okay so those are the
terminologies in tensorflow terms
dimensions and ranks so this is just to
make sure that we are picking the same
language so whenever we talk about the
rank of a tensor you understand what
exactly is meant by that now in addition
to tensors in which the data is actually
stored all right so the data is stored
in the tensors and then once you have
the data there is a computation that
needs to be done now the computation
happens in the form of graphs so what we
typically in a tensorflow program what
we do is it's not like traditional
programming where you just write a bunch
of lines and then everything gets
executed in sequence here we prepare
graphs various nodes and then these are
executed in the form of a session and
they use the data from these tensors now
i know this is a slightly new concept
for a lot of you so it may be a little
difficult to probably understand in the
first cut but when we look at the code
when we go into the tutorial the code
walkthrough i think that time it will
become much clearer as well but to start
with just uh we need to keep in mind
that we have to first prepare a graph
and when you're preparing the graph no
none of the code is actually getting
executed you write the code to prepare
the graph and then you execute that
graph so that's the way by creating a
session that's the way tensorflow
program works so and each of these
computation is represented as what is
known as a data flow graph and we will
also see that whenever you start
tensorflow when you create an object
tensorflow object there will be what is
known as the default graph and then if
required i know probably in the
beginning it may not be required but in
more advanced programming you can
actually have multiple graphs instead of
the default graph you can create your
own graph and have multiple graphs and
use it as well but there is always
whenever you create a tensorflow object
there will be a default graph and this
will be very nicely illustrated in the
example code that we will take to
explain this so there it becomes much
clearer than in these slides so the
graph gets executed and it processes all
the data that we are feeding all the
external data will be fed in the form of
what is known as placeholders and then
you have variables and constants again
this will also become clear when we take
a look at the code and once you have the
graph then the execution can be enabled
either on regular cpus or on gpus and
also in a distributed mode so that the
processing becomes much faster as i
mentioned the training of the models in
deep learning takes extremely long
because of the large amount of data and
therefore using tensorflow actually
makes it much easier to write the code
for gpus or cpus and then execute it in
a distributed manner so this is how the
tensorflow program looks so there is uh
you need to build a computational graph
that's the first step and then you
execute that graph so the first step is
to write the code for preparing the
graph and then you create what is known
as a session and then in that session
you ask the session to execute this
graph so this will again become much
clearer when we look at the core before
we can see the differences between these
platforms we first need to know what
exactly each of these platforms are
let's start with tensorflow what is
tensorflow tensorflow is a low level
software library which is created by
google to help implement machine
learning models and to solve complex
numerical problems
tensorflow is nothing but a free and
open source software library for machine
learning
it can be used across a range of tasks
but has a particular focus on training
and inference of deep neural networks
tensorflow is a symbolic math library
based on data flow and differential
programming it is used for both research
and production at google
what do you mean by data flow it
basically means that we perform
calculations by converting every element
into graphical form
the variables of the graph are called
tensors and mathematical operations are
called operators
here in the computational graph shown
you can see that x y and 2 are the
variables they will also be called
tensors and division multiplication and
addition are the operators
this graph basically shows us the
calculation that is going to occur in a
machine learning model
where x and y are going to be divided
and y and 2 are going to be multiplied
the results of these two calculations
are then going to be added to give us
the final output i told you that x y and
2 are also called tensors
what exactly are tensors
tensors are multi-dimensional arrays
with a uniform type all tensors are
immutable like python numbers and
strings which means that you cannot
update the contents of a tensor you can
only create a new tensor next let's look
at the api keras
what exactly is keras keras is a high
level deep learning api written in
python for easy implementation and
computation of neural networks keras is
an open source software library that
provides a tensorflow interface for
artificial neural networks keras acts as
an interface for the tensorflow library
which means that it runs on top of
tensorflow
up until version 2.3 keras supported
multiple back-ends
including tensorflow microsoft cognitive
toolkit
or cntk
r theano and played ml
as of version 2.4 only tensorflow is
supported
as a version 2.4 only tensorflow is
designed to help enable fast
experimentation with deep neural
networks in it focuses on being user
friendly modular and extensible
keras is a high level api of tensorflow
an approachable highly productive
interface for solving machine learning
problems with the focus on modern deep
learning it provides essential
abstractions and building blocks for
developing
and shipping machine learning solutions
with high iteration velocity keras does
not perform its own low level operations
such as tensor products and convolution
it relies on back-end engines for that
even though keras supports multiple
back-end engines its primary back-end
engine is tensorflow and its primary
supporter is google which means that
keras acts as nothing more but a wrapper
class around tensorflow theano cntk
blade ml or mxnet which are low level
apis next we will look at pi torch what
exactly is pytoch
pytoch is a low level api which is
developed by facebook for natural
language processing and computer vision
it is a more powerful version of numpy
it is an open source machine learning
library based on the torch library used
for applications such as computer vision
and natural language processing
primarily developed by facebook's ai
research lab it is free and open source
software released under the modified bsd
license although the python interface is
a more polished and the primary focus of
development pytorch also has a c plus
plus interface python is a widely liked
language because it is easy to
understand and write pytorch emphasizes
flexibility and allows deep learning
models to be expressed in basic python
pytorch is mainly used for natural
language processing
and for computer vision now let's move
on to the differences between tensorflow
keras and pytorch
the first difference that we'll be
looking at is called level of api there
are two main types of apis a low level
api and a high level api api stands for
application programming interface
a low level application programming
interface is generally more detailed and
allows you to have more detailed control
to manipulate functions within them on
how to use and implement them
while a high level api is more generic
and simple and provides more
functionality with one command
statements than a lower level api
high level interfaces are comparatively
easier to learn and to implement the
models using them
they allow you to write code in a
shorter amount of time and to be less
involved with the details
in this case tensorflow is a high and
low level api
pure tensorflow is a low level api while
tensorflow wrapped in keras is a high
level api
keras in itself is a high level api
which uses multiple low level apis as a
back back-end and simplifies the
operation of these low-level apis
pi torch is a low-level api
the next criteria that we'll be looking
at is speed
tensorflow is very fast and is used for
high performances keras is slower as it
works on top of tensorflow not only does
it have to wait for tensorflow to finish
implementation it then starts its own
implementation
meanwhile pi torch works at the same
speed as tensorflow as both of them are
both low level apis
now keras is a wrapper class for
tensorflow and has added abstraction
functionalities on top of tensorflow
which make it slower than tensorflow and
pi torch in computation speed both
tensorflow and pytorch are almost equal
and in development speed keras is faster
as it has built-in functionalities which
can significantly reduce your
development time
the next difference is on the
architecture
tensorflow is not very easy to use and
even though it provides keras as a
framework that makes it work easier
tensorflow still has a very complex
architecture which is hard to use
meanwhile keras has a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in keras significantly easier pie touch
on the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to keras tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pie touch is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes
data sets and debugging
tensorflow works with large data sets
due to its high execution speed and
debugging is really hard in tensorflow
due to its complex nature
meanwhile keras only works with very
small data sets as its speed of
execution is low
programs do not require frequent
debugging in keras as they are
relatively simpler and by torch can
manage high level tasks in higher
dimension data sets and is easier to
debug than both qrs and tensorflow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development
as we said before tensorflow works with
many
hard concepts such as computational
graphs and tensors which means that
writing code in tensorflow is very hard
it is generally used by people when they
are doing research work and really need
very specific functionalities
keras on the other hand provides a high
level of abstraction which makes it very
easy to use it is best for people who
are just starting out with python and
machine learning pytorch is easier than
tensorflow but is still comparatively
hard than keras it is not
very easy to learn for beginners but is
significantly more powerful than just
plain keras ease of deployment
tensorflow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensorflow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production
environments tensorflow serving makes it
easy to deploy new algorithms and
experiments while keeping the same
server architecture and apis
tensorflow serving provides
out-of-the-box integration with
tensorflow models but can be easily
extended to serve other types of models
and data in keras model deployment can
be done with either tensorflow serving
or flask which makes it relatively easy
but not as easy as you as it would be
with tensorflow and pytorch
pytorch uses itouch mobile which makes
deployment easy but again for tensorflow
deployment is way easier as tensorflow
serving can update your machine learning
back end on the fly without
the user even realizing there's a
growing need to execute ml models on
edge devices to reduce latency preserve
privacy and enable new interactive use
cases in the past engineers used to
train models separately they would then
go through a multi-step error-prone and
often complex process to train the
models for execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience
all of these frictions have been removed
by pytorch mobile by allowing a seamless
process to go from training to
deployment by staying entirely within
the pi torch ecosystem
it provides an end-to-end workflow that
simplifies the research to production
environment for mobile devices
in addition it paves the way for privacy
preserving features via federated
learning techniques
at the end of the day the question that
really matters is which framework should
you use keras tensorflow or pytorch
now tensorflow has implemented various
levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier keras is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensorflow it is
more user friendly than any other deep
learning api however and is easier to
learn for beginners
pytorch on the other hand is the
preferred deep learning api for teachers
but it is not as widely used in
production as tensorflow is it is faster
but it has lower gpu utilization
at the end of the day
the framework that we would suggest that
you use is tensorflow
why
while pytorch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tensorflow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production
pytorch's ease of use combined with the
default ego execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky solutions and smaller scale
models but tensorflow's extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
overhead makes it the preferred option
for companies that work with deep
learning models in addition the
tensorflow board visualization features
offers a nice way of showing the inner
workings of your model to save your
customers
meanwhile between tensorflow and keras
the main difference isn't in performance
tensorflow is a bit faster due to less
overhead but also the level of control
you would like keras is much easier to
start with than plain tensorflow but if
you want to do something with keras that
doesn't come out of the box it will be
harder to implement that tensorflow on
the other hand allows you to create any
arbitrary computational graph providing
much more flexibility so if you're doing
more research type of work tensorflow is
the sure route to go due to the
flexibility that it provides welcome to
the session on installing tensorflow my
name is mohan and i'm going to take you
through the process of setting up this
tensorflow development environment as
some of you may be aware it's not that
easy to set up the tensorflow
environment there are several components
there are several possibilities for
example
you can set up on windows you can set up
on ubuntu now ubuntu has multiple
versions which version to use and then
you have python which release of python
to use whether to do a pip install
whether to do install using anaconda and
how do you then link it up with jupyter
notebook these are multiple
possibilities and it takes up a lot of
time to try all of these so today what
i'm going to do is show you a tried and
tested method of setting up the
tensorflow environment and this will
help primarily those who are starting
with tensorflow so that they don't have
to waste so much time on setting up the
environment in experimenting with the
insulation and setting up of the
environment now what we are going to do
is i will show you a method by which you
you know it is a tried and tested method
and of course tensorflow home page has a
install page and it shows you some ways
to install but again the challenge is
the same there are multiple versions
multiple methods shown there so it's
highly confusing for somebody who is new
as to decide which one which path to
take so in today's session what we are
going to do is we will set up tensorflow
on ubuntu and i'm going to show you in a
virtual box but then if you are using a
laptop with ubuntu installed you can
straight away use the same method
however we need to keep one thing in
mind that the various releases and
versions of ubuntu and
python and tensorflow not all of them
are compatible with each other so these
versions and releases need to be very
specific so i will tell you which is the
version and releases what combination is
best suited for you to get started and
later on of course you can then
experiment with other possibilities and
other releases and so on once you get
familiar with tensorflow to start with i
would also like to mention that it is a
good idea to install or start with
ubuntu environment or linux any other
linux also but here we will focus on
ubuntu rather than windows so for those
who are already let's say using a
windows system the question may arise
what do we do but there is an easy
option as you can see i'm actually using
a virtual box so you need to install
virtualbox let me just show you so this
is the virtual box oracle vm virtual box
and there are tons of videos on youtube
how to install
a virtual box and how to create ubuntu
image i think we will not spend time on
that but if you're using windows and my
preference would be to set up a virtual
box and
set up your environment in ubuntu image
so we will start by assuming that you
have an ubuntu environment especially
release
14.04 lts there are multiple ubuntu
versions and again we will not try to
get the latest and the greatest versions
or latest and greatest releases but the
focus here is to take the releases and
versions which are working and where you
will not waste time so the setup process
will be smooth if you stick to these
releases you can of course experiment
later on with other versions and try out
but here we will be working with ubuntu
1404 lts and we will use python 3.4 and
we will use tensorflow 1.5 this is a
tried and tested combination and i would
also recommend that you use the same if
you want a smooth start and so let's get
started with that
let me login to my open the system okay
so we have the ubuntu system running
here now if you go to tensorflow.org
there is a page which
mentions how to install tensorflow and
as you can see there are multiple
possibilities you have ubuntu you have
windows and mac os and so on and so
forth and if you go to ubuntu for
example further you will get
multiple options whether you want cpu or
gpu and
whether you want to do a pip install or
using a virtual native pip virtual env
anaconda and so on and so forth so all
these options are very complicated or
rather very confusing i would say not
complicated depending on whether you're
expert or of course i am talking about
beginners here but if you click on some
of these options they may look very easy
so for example if you go back and uh if
you select for example native pip it may
appear like oh this is just you know one
single or two steps and that's about it
everything gets installed you see here
it should be just one step install it
you say pip3 install tensorflow and
everything gets installed unfortunately
it doesn't work that way so it's not as
easy as so don't get kind of fooled by
the simplicity of the of the
documentation here again it's not their
fault because of the multiple
combinations of releases and so on and
so forth it is not that easy so what we
will do is we will take a slightly
roundabout method which is using
anaconda which has a few more steps but
you're sure that this is going to work
so that is what we are going to do and
that's what i am going to show you so
what are the steps involved of course i
will not go exactly by what they have
mentioned here as i said i will show you
the steps which are again sure shot to
work whereas
here again if you follow just this
document there will be some variations
which they have kind of not documented
so that's the reason i will show you the
steps separately all right so these are
the main four steps you need to download
and install anaconda and then create a
virtual environment with python and the
release as i mentioned is python 3.4 and
we will install tensorflow version 1.5
and then we will install and configure
jupiter which will be our development
environment all right so let's get
started this is our ubuntu and
let's get a terminal started here and
okay yes so
all right so we started the terminal and
then what we'll also do is we'll go to
the anaconda website because we need to
install anaconda we need to download and
install anaconda so for that you need to
go to the anaconda website so you can
just open a browser and
google and you will find anaconda
website
so this is the site anaconda.org
click on this link and it will take you
to the anaconda website
you don't have to sign up or anything
like that just look for the download
anaconda
so just click on that it will take you
to the download pages and it
automatically recognizes that you are on
ubuntu so it will show you the links to
download all right so as you can see it
has
recognized that you are on a linux
operating system so
you can just click on this download and
it will start the download there are two
versions of course python with python
3.6 and 2.7 i
recommend you start with python 3.6 now
just want to clarify that we will be
actually using python 3.4 this is just
for
the initial installation but
subsequently when we set up the virtual
environment you will see there is one
more step there where we set up the
virtual environment there we will
actually be using python 3.4 so just
that you are not confused all right so
it has started the download we just say
no thanks for this
and it is downloading while it is
downloading you can
click on this
link saying how to install anaconda so
there are a couple of steps mentioned
there that we will be using so let me
just in the meanwhile click on this for
some reason the network is a little slow
so it's taking time all right so
once the download is done we will be
using the options that are mentioned
here now the first step of course is we
we are already doing the first step
which is downloading the installer for
linux the second step is not mandatory
so it's an optional step most often you
can actually skip that and third step is
what we are going to do and
since we are using at this point we are
using python 3.6 we should use this
command so basically
the terminal we have opened here is is
to use or to run this command that's the
reason i opened this terminal however
make sure that the download is complete
before you run this command so we'll
just wait for a couple of minutes and
we'll come back once the download is
done all right so as you can see the
download is done this is a fairly large
file so if you are on a slow internet or
low internet bandwidth then it might
take quite a while it's about
578 mb and so this is the file now what
you need to do is
you need to go back to this installation
steps and let me minimize this and
yeah so
this is the command that you need to run
so you can just directly copy and paste
this command from here
okay so i do copy right mouse click
now it will ask you a bunch of questions
as documented here so most of them you
need to just say enter or yes and that's
about it except for the last step i will
just show you what i mean and we need to
do press enter multiple times just to
make sure you agree to all these
agreement uh the license agreement and
so on and so forth so once you do
multiple
enters it will
bring you to the next step
all right so now here again they say do
you accept the terms you just say yes
and then press enter and here it will
ask you a couple of questions and pretty
much you need to just go for the default
version press enter to confirm you just
say press enter and
this is primarily when it will
pretty much start the installation
process of anaconda this might take a
little while depending again on your
internet speed so you need to have some
patience we will also probably come back
once this installation is done or if it
asks for any further questions
all right so here you'll get again one
more question do you used to
wish the installer to prepend
so you just say yes for this question
and
keep going now the last question
i think we are pretty much at the end
and that is about microsoft
vss i guess
yeah we escort so for this you can just
say no because we will not be using this
and
that's it you're done so this is a
completion of
installation of anaconda so it's always
a good idea to exit and start a fresh
terminal
okay so
let's start again terminal
so we are done with the
installation of anaconda the next step
is to create a virtual environment with
python 3.4 so for that this is the
command conda create dash n
and this is the name of your virtual
environment you can give any name but
for easy reference i have given us
tensorflow and we have to specify the
python version as i mentioned earlier we
will be using the combination of python
3.4 and
tensorflow 1.5 now this is not the
latest version python has probably 3.6
at this point at the time of creation of
this video and even tensorflow probably
has the latest version as 1.7 but then
these combinations sometimes may not
work and i found that after several
trials and errors 3.4 with 1.5 seems to
be most reliable and that's the reason i
have chosen this i would recommend you
to try with this first if you're a
beginner and later on maybe you can try
out the other permutations and
combinations all right one step i just
wanted to show you is before we do the
installation or creation of the virtual
environment if you want to just clarify
or confirm whether anaconda has been
installed or not you can run what is
known as anaconda navigator so just say
anaconda
navigator
okay we need to edit this part hold on
one second i guess it is
all right so you see here when you start
anaconda navigator
this
anaconda navigator will open up that is
the indication that anaconda has been
installed
properly so that's just a quick check
and you don't have to do anything just
you can
go back and close it
once this comes up and
then in the meanwhile let me just open
one more terminal
for the creation of the
virtual environment and
yeah so this is your anaconda navigator
and you can just say okay don't show me
and just say okay
and
then you can close this
you can say file you can do a file exit
or you can click on close button
whichever
all right so we will exit from here
we have a
terminal open here we will use this for
our next steps all right so what we have
to do now is
type in
this
piece of
code
or this command
for some reason copy paste is not
working so
it's a small command so it shouldn't be
that big of an issue so we say conda
[Music]
and we say
create
so this is the command for creating a
new environment slash
dash n
and then we give the name of the
environment so we will we can give any
name for
convenience i'm just calling it
tensorflow
but you can actually name it anything
and then we need to specify with the
which version of python so we say pip
[Music]
python
and then that is equal
3.4 okay so it will create an
environment this will take a little
while it will ask you a question just
say yes and then it will be done
so this is just a warning you can simply
ignore that
and
for the question that it asks you just
say yes and i think you should be good
all right so it says do you want to
proceed you say yes then enter
this will again take a little little
time so we will probably move forward
and then come back once this is done
all right so
the environment has been created now
it's always a good idea to whenever some
of these steps get over or each step
gets over you just exit the terminal and
start afresh with a new terminal for
some reason sometimes it causes problem
if you continue so i found that it is a
safe practice to each time exit the
terminal and start afresh now that we
have an environment created
we can by the name tensorflow
you can
enter that environment
by calling the command source
activate
[Music]
tensorflow to name whatever name you
have given so you'll see here once you
do that you will get this the name of
the environment will be shown here so it
is like your own again a special
environment within within the system and
uh from here onwards you can do other
stuff like actually installing
tensorflow and so on and you will see
that it has installed python 3 here so
3.4 right so it is installed that's what
we during creation of this environment
we wanted python 3.4 so that is what it
is showing but we are not yet done so we
need to still install tensorflow so in
this environment you need to
run a command which will actually
install the correct combination
of tensorflow now this is as you can see
it's a slightly complicated command with
install
dash dash ignore install so
what we can do is from within here we
can go and
go to tensorflow
install page and there is a sample code
there you can pick up from there so that
you don't have to type in
so much
so we say tensorflow tensor
flow
dark and i'll also open up probably a
notepad here so that we can construct
that command and go here
you say
ubuntu
if you come further down
there will be by the way we are doing
cpu installation i think uh that is
clear we are not there is a possibility
to do gpu as well we will probably
create a separate video for that
and
um if we go here
yeah so
again you probably if you follow the
entire document out here it may still
not work so i do not recommend that for
now at least for beginners but just to
copy this command because this is a
fairly complicated command so this is
much easier to copy it from here that's
the reason
on this page and we will
then modify it according to
yes okay let's say
copy
and don't do it directly here because
that is probably not yet the right
command
let us go and create a notepad
page
empty document
i'll just say
tf.txt
okay this is just a temporary file what
we need to do here is we need to adjust
this command to suit the versions that
we are installing here so let me just
explain what it is what you need to do
so first thing you can get rid of
this one
yes okay now here these parts you can
simply ignore
here you need to go and change it to
version
1.5
and i think we are good with that okay
so the cp34 indicates your python 3.4
so later on when you're trying to
experiment and if you want to
do other combinations of tensorflow and
python version then you can change this
for example you can change this to 3 6
both these places you need to change
this to 3 6 if you are using with python
3.6 and similarly if you want the latest
version which is of tensorflow which is
1.7 you need to change this to 1.7 and
so on but at this point to start with if
you're a beginner i would recommend that
you stick to this tensorflow 1.5 with
python 3.4 this is tried and tested and
it works okay just a word of caution
that just by changing these versions
the whole thing
will not work there may be other places
where you may have to some of the steps
may change so just a word of caution
that just by changing this if you want
to try out with a different version some
of the steps may also change so don't
think that just by changing this just
one particular command you will be fine
okay so
that's been my experience so to start
with i would recommend use this
particular combination all right so
it looks good
uh tensorflow 1.5 and
let me
just reconfirm with my notes and i think
it looks good so this is install ignore
1.5 cp34 cp34
and so on okay
so let's hit enter
so it started the process again this
might take a little while so we will
pause the recording and then get back
when the installation is done okay so
looks like this installation is done
and as always let us
exit and then come back now
you are currently in the environment
virtual environment
and it's a good practice before you exit
out of the terminal to come out doctor
out of the virtual environment so just
like you did source activate you need to
do source deactivate
and the name tensor
flow okay you will come back to the
original command prompt and then from
here you can
do an exit now we need to validate
whether the tensorflow installation has
gone through properly or not so
the way to validate is to
first start python and then import
tensorflow library see if it imports
without error so that's the best way to
validate so we'll open a terminal
and whenever you want to get into
the environment this is how you have to
do come to environment and then say
source and obviously you can also use
existing
so source activate
tensorflow okay so we do this and you
need to run python from here remember
you should say python3 because you have
installed python 3.4 now here when you
say import
tensorflow
as tf
when you get back a prompt like this
without any errors that means tensorflow
installation has been successful if
tensorflow was not installed properly
you will get an error saying tensorflow
is not available or module doesn't exist
or something like that so tensorflow
installation is done but now we will
go through the process of installing
jupyter notebook so that you can do your
development so let me just exit
and in order to install your jupyter
notebook which is your which is going to
be your development environment we will
first
install ipython using conda so conda
install ipython and then pip install
jupiter so let's first do the
ipython conda
install
hide python
again it will ask you a question saying
these are the components do you want to
install you just say yes
all right you say yes
once again it will take a little while
so we might pause the recording and come
back once it is done
great so that did not take much time
anyways so we will
as usual we will exit which is
source deactivate
tensorflow
exit and then we will start a fresh
terminal in order to install
jupiter
now in some places
they may say
install jupiter using victory but in my
experience it did not work with big 3
and that's the reason we will use pip
however just keep in mind you need to
first go to the environment so
source activate
tensorflow
and you need to use this command which
is pip install jupyter usually when
you're on python 3 you use pip3 but as i
said it did not work so
in my experience it works with
install and not pic3 so pip install
jupiter
i hope you already noticed that it is
j-u-p-y d-e-r
and not jbi
so again it's probably taking a little
while we will pause the recording and
come back once it is done
okay so jupyter installation is also
done
once again
you need to it's a good idea not you
need to but it's a good idea to
come out of this terminal session and
then start afresh
so we exit and we have a fresh terminal
already available here
and we will once again
go to tensorflow
and we say
jupiter
notebook
that's how you start your jupyter
so this looks good now only thing is
since we are running
for the first time what you need to do
is if you come back to your command
prompt
it will show you that if you are running
it for the first time it will say that
you need to copy paste this link so
you you can just for the first time only
once you need to do this
copy this
and
paste it in your
browser
and remember this is only the first time
when you're running jupiter you need to
do this
subsequently you don't have to it will
automatically
open up all right so now that we have
jupiter installed and
it starts up we need to test whether
tensorflow
is working fine or not and in order to
do that
you can create a new
notebook
and you say
import
tensorflow
as tf and shift enter if everything is
fine tensorflow is installed properly
you don't get any errors and then it
works fine this is
an indication that tensorflow got
installed successfully
and that's about it so that's all about
installing tensorflow with python 3.4 so
remember this is installation of
tensorflow 1.5 with python 3.4
on ubuntu and
once again in case you have a windows
system in fact i have also done it on a
windows system you can
use virtual blocks to create a virtual
environment ubuntu environment and then
follow these steps
and there are tons of videos to create
virtual box and that's the reason
we have not included those steps in this
and if there are any comments there are
better ways to do this please mention it
in the comment section below or if you
need any further help just mention it
and with your email we will respond to
you now what are the various elements of
a tensorflow program as i mentioned
tensorflow program is slightly different
from regular programming that we do so
even if you're familiar with python this
may still be new for you the way you
write a tensorflow program is different
from the regular python programming that
you would have done or even machine
learning program you would have written
some machine learning program using
scikit-learn or regular python libraries
this is different from even that so let
us see what are the various elements so
first of all the way we handle data
inside of a program itself is a little
different from how we normally do in a
normal programming language a variable
is a variable in your program right so
you have anything that can keep changing
you just create as a variable or even
constants in fact are actually created
as variables but in tensorflow the
storage in the program consists of three
types one is constants another is
variable and the third is a placeholder
so and they are there is a lot of
difference between these types and we
will see how they vary and how they are
used and so on so constants are like
variables which cannot be changed so for
example if you define a constant like
this this is how you define a constant
by the way the simplest format is like
this like for example b is equal to tf
dot constant and then you give a value
here the slightly more advanced version
is you also specify the type so you say
tf dot constant 2.0 tf load 32 so the
type is of type float now in case of
constants you cannot during the
computation you cannot really change
these values so for example if you want
to change the value of b from 3 to 5 or
any other number it is not possible so
that is the meaning of constant all
right so then we have variables so
variables we are all familiar with what
are variables whenever we use
programming we use variables so this is
pretty much the same this is the way you
define variables df dot variable now one
thing you need to note is this is the
only type in which we have v capital
okay constant has c the small c and
placeholder as small p but variable as
capital v and tf dot variable and then
you give the a value and then you can
specify what is the type and then you
can use the variable change the variable
at any point in time with a different
value and so on you can update the
variable and so on so we will see all of
this in the code i will illustrate how a
variable is defined and how it can be
changed whereas a constant cannot be
changed and so on and so forth and then
we have placeholders placeholders are
really a special type and this may be
something completely new for many of us
who have been doing programming but in
tensorflow this is a completely new
concept so this is very important to
understand this placeholders are like
variables but only thing is that they
are used for feeding the data from
outside so typically when you are
performing some computations you need to
load data from a file or from an image
file or from a csv file or whatever so
there is a provision with the special
kind of variables which can be fed in a
regular basis because the reason one of
the reasons for having this kind of
provision is that if you get the entire
input in one shot typically it may be
very difficult to handle the memory and
so on so i think that was the reason
they came up with this mechanism where
you can feed in patches and there is a
certain way of populating the
placeholder we call this feed dig feed
underscore dick and this is a parameter
name by the way and you feed the
placeholders right that is the meaning
here so there is a certain way of
feeding the placeholders and we will
again see this in the example code as we
move forward okay so there are three
types one is the constant which cannot
be changed once you assign a value then
you have variables which are like normal
variables we are all familiar with and
then you have placeholders this is
primarily for feeding data from usually
from outside but of course you can also
for temporary testing purpose you can
feed within the program as well but
primarily the purpose of a placeholder
is to get data from outside so all right
so those were the constants variables
and placeholders that is how you
handle data within the tensorflow
program and then you create a graph and
once you create a graph then you have
what is known as a session and then you
create a session object and you create a
session and then you run a particular
computation or a node or an operation
and so typically what you need to do is
every variable or a computation that you
perform is like an operation or a node
within a graph so initially the graph
will be what is known as the default
graph the moment you create a tensorflow
object or tf this tf here you see this
is the tensorflow object and again in
the code when we go into the code it
will become much easier to understand so
when you create a tensorflow object
there is like a default graph which
doesn't have any operations no nodes or
anything like that so it's like a clean
slate the moment you
assign variables or constants or
placeholders each of them is in
tensorflow terms it is known as an
operation again you need to get familiar
with these terms and they are not very
intuitive this is not really an
operation you are just creating a
constant or a variable but and this c is
equal to a into b would traditionally or
would intuitively be an operation here
you're actually performing an operation
but in tensorflow terms each of these
everything is an operation so if you're
creating a constant that is an operation
another constant or variable that's an
operation so you can actually run each
of these and they're also known as
referred to as nodes and when you're in
your session you will actually
run each of these you can potentially
run each of these nodes okay so a
typical example would look like this so
you have two constants created a is
equal to tf.constant its value is 5 b is
equal to this and then you say c is
equal to a into b and then you create a
session now remember all this you're
just creating a graph at this point no
execution has happened all right so only
at this point once you create a session
and then you say session or says dot run
c is when actually this whole thing will
get executed all right so that is a
different way of programming compared to
our traditional way of writing programs
so you need to get used to this new
format and when we look at the code as
we move forward and when we look in the
jupiter notebook it will become much
easier probably to understand this
rather than in the slide so these are
the slides showing the code but what we
can do is go straight into the
lab and take a look at the various
examples that are there and starting
from the very basic one how you create
variables and so these are some of the
slides that are showing so this is about
how to create variables how to create
constants and the variables or constants
can also be strings so this is like our
first hello world program and we will
talk about placeholders how to define a
placeholder and how to execute and
populate the placeholder values into
placeholder we will see these examples
in the lab actually i will run the code
and
we will also perform a small computation
of adding and multiplying these
variables and we will in the end we will
take up a use case implementation using
tensorflow so let's first go and see
those examples and then come back and
i'll explain this use case and then we
will execute the use case in the lab so
let's go and check our lab okay so i'm
in the jupiter notebook environment and
this is one of the development
environments we can use this is regular
python anytime you do python programming
we use gypted notebook or there are
rather of course there are other ways of
using other tools like pycharm and so on
but for this particular tutorial i'm
comfortable using jupyter notebook so i
will show you in jupyter notebook so
this is the very basic example to
demonstrate how to create variables and
constants and placeholders and what is
the difference between them how they
behave and so on and as i mentioned the
assumption here is that you know at
least some basic python programming or
some programming language so at least
you understand the code here and first
two pieces of code you will not need
machine learning background but when we
do the use case or the case study there
it is expected that you know at least
some basic machine learning concepts so
in case you need to brush up the machine
learning part you may have to do that
before you go to the third one but here
just at least some idea of programming
will be sufficient so what are we doing
here in this particular line or in this
particular cell we are importing
tensorflow it is uh as i mentioned it is
a library so we are importing tensorflow
and we are calling it tf so this is just
a name you can give it any name but it
is very common and everywhere wherever
tensorflow programming is done it is
always named as tf but you can name
anything actually okay so this will
import the tensorflow into my session
now this is the way to create a variable
so let's start by creating a variable
and this is the name of my variable i'm
starting by giving a name called 0 and i
say 0 is equal to tf dot variable and
then i'm giving the value of the
variable here so this is the very basic
way and the simplest way to create a
variable you will see a little later
there are other formats as well but the
bare minimum way of creating a variable
is this so i'm creating a variable by
the name zero and as i mentioned you
need to pay attention to the capital v
here in case of variable it is a capital
v uppercase constant and placeholders
are
lowercase now i'm creating a constant
then the constant i'm naming it as one
and the way to create a constant is tf
dot constant and then you give the value
of the constant so the value of the
variable here is zero and the value of
constant here is one and again constant
you can also have additional parameters
like a name and so on probably you must
have seen in other tutorials or in other
places where the code is written but the
basic format to construct to create a
constant is this this is sufficient to
create a constant so i created one
variable and one constant now what else
can we do again here there is no real
execution happening we are just building
a graph we have not yet executed any
tensorflow code we are building a graph
and i will show you how the graph looks
as well first let us understand the
constants and variables and so on and
then i will show you how the graph is
generated and so on so what i want to do
here is i want to add
0 and 1 and put it into a new variable
called new value so what i do here
tensorflow offers these methods like add
assign multiply or
you have matrix multiplication matmul
and so on right so i will use one of
those methods which is tf.add and then
pass these two as parameters so we can
add a variable and a constant there are
no restrictions on that so this is a
variable and this is a constant so if i
do this it will be okay i did not
execute this code so it is giving an
error now we are good okay so what it
has done is new value will be equal to
tf dot add 0 1 so then we have one
variable and one constant now let's say
i want to change the value of the
variable because that is possible right
so we want to change the value of the
variable to something some new value so
we have in this case new value has one
because we added a zero and a one so new
value has one now i want to assign this
to this originally what we called as
zero so i will call that as update is
equal to tf dot assign so assign is
basically changing the value so that's
what we we're going to do here now it
has not complained we'll just say fine
right there are no issues now let us try
this something similar
with this 1 as well so 0 is a variable
so we were able to change the value and
we will in a little while we will see
what exactly those values are but before
doing that now let's say i will
uncomment this part and i want to do
something similar for my constant right
1 is a constant now i want to let's say
change the value of the constant and
make that also something different okay
so if i execute this piece of code it
will give an error now again the error
message may not be very intuitive this
doesn't say that you cannot do this for
a constant it will just say tensor
object has no attribute assign now that
sometimes may be confusing especially
when you are starting but the meaning
here is that one is a constant and you
are trying to modify the constant so it
will not allow that's the reason it is
complaining so let's put that back in
the comment and
okay so that is done so only variables
you can modify now what you have to do
let's skip this piece of code i'll come
back to this in a bit
but let's say we start by creating you
remember i told you we need to create a
session so the way to create a session
there are a couple of ways of creating a
session but this is for beginners this
is the easiest way all you need to do is
assign a variable called says or you can
give any name and that is equal to tf
dot session that is the session method
here and you create a session object by
the name says now what i'll do is i'll
skip this as well i there is a purpose
behind that now let's go ahead and run
this piece of particular operation
remember i mentioned that everything you
need to run so as of now the code has
not really got executed tensorflow code
has not got executed you only created
the graph so only when you
run through the session is when that
actually the program gets executed so
when you do this now you see observe
that it is giving an error okay the
reason behind that is remember we skip
these two lines of code for variables
okay this and then this now this is
something very very important to observe
if you have variables in your code what
i mean by that is let's say you are not
using variables but you have only
constants and placeholders then this
will not complain and you will not get
this error but in our case we also have
variables so whenever you have variables
in that case you need to do an
initialization and this is just a
standard code there is nothing that we
need to add or modify or anything like
that this is a standard piece of code
you create this name of course can be
anything you can give us any name but
this global variables initializer is
what you need to call tf.global
variables initializer this will kind of
initialize all the variables that you
may be using and then again remember
this doesn't execute anything right so
all you're doing here is you're creating
an operation but in order to run that
operation you need to also run this
known as run init underscore op so this
operation you need to run after creating
the session all right so we executed
this now let us execute this and now
when i run this piece of code it will
run successfully okay i hope you
observed that so it is whenever you use
variables these two lines of code one is
the operation you need to create an
operation for saying global variables
initializer and then you need to run
before running anything else you need to
do a session.run this operation okay
again only if you're using variables of
course you invariably in all your
programs you will use variables you
cannot just write a program with
constants and placeholders so you can
pretty much assume that this has to be
there in pretty much all the programs
now again why
this has not been taken care of in the
library that's a different question but
you need to keep in mind and always
remember if you don't do this for
whatever reason if you're forgotten you
will get an error and the error won't be
intuitive so you need to remember this
that this could be because of the
variables okay good so we have seen how
to create a constant and we have seen
how to create a variable and we have
seen that you cannot modify or update a
constant and we have also seen if you
have variables that you need to execute
or have these two lines of code to
initialize the variables and then we
have seen that after creating a graph
how to run the graph in a session and i
will show you a little bit more in
detail how exactly the graph gets
created and how it gets executed but
this was the first very quick code on
creating variables and constants now we
will keep going and
we will also show you or i will show you
the placeholders but before that one
more small piece of code so this is how
you write a for loop okay so we are
saying five times you run this piece of
code now like any python program this is
nothing different so you have a for loop
and this is indented that's the reason
and therefore you say session.run update
so this will run five times and it will
get printed that's all so update will
run for five times each time it will
come and do this particular operation
that's all we are we are asking the
system to do so let me just run that and
show you let me yeah so it will
okay so it has done five times
one that's four it is basically adding
if you recall it starts from zero it
adds one to zero then one to one one to
two and so on so it's nothing but it is
generating five numbers one two three
four five that's it okay so then
you can also have your constants as
strings for example so you can also work
in a similar way you can work with
string so most of the computation
happens
mainly on numerical values so we
normally hand handle numbers but
there will be situations where you may
have to handle strings as well or text
as well so this is an example of text
operations so you can similar to numbers
you just create strings or store
in constants instead of a number you say
hello is equal to tf.constant and then
you assign the string that you want it
to be assigned and then the next one is
one more string which is for world and
then you say add these two so it is
nothing but concatenation of these two
words hello and
world
so we will do that and remember this is
only creation of the graph right so in
order to actually execute this graph you
need to run the session now you need to
keep in mind we don't have to create the
session once again because once you
create a session till you close the
session it remains valid okay so we have
created this session here now till you
say says dot close it will remain for
you so that's why we did not create one
more so we are just reusing that session
says dot run hello world so in this
hello world what is the operation that
we are doing here the operation is add
these two concatenate these two so if i
run this it will print hello world okay
now that's string operation now we will
take a look at placeholders so this is
slightly more complicated and something
new even for people who have been
writing programs so but i'll just
explain it with uh with a quick example
first of all how do you declare or
create a placeholder you just do
tf.placeholder and the p is lowercase
only in case of variables the b is
uppercase but otherwise constant and
placeholder as it is lowercase and you
just say because as i mentioned this is
a placeholder it doesn't have any value
so you unlike a constant or your
variable you can't usually you will not
specify any value you just say what type
of placeholder you want and very often
most of the cases it is a floating point
so we just say placeholder of type
float32 so this tf dot float32 tells the
system that it is a floating point okay
and then so let me just run this and
then you can do some or define some
computation like for example b is equal
to a into 2. now remember here right now
a has no value but what we are saying
here is at any point later on when a
gets some value then b should be equal
to twice the value of a that's all we
are saying here okay and also as i
mentioned earlier we are not yet
executing anything we're just creating
the graph here okay so now you have that
now how do you feed the value or
populate the placeholder there is a
certain syntax in which you can populate
the placeholder and you do that using
what is known as a dictionary you're all
probably familiar those with python
especially must be familiar with the
dictionaries so you need to create a
dictionary and then pass that
in order to feed the placeholder so in
this particular example if i want to run
something if i want to calculate or
compute b obviously i need to feed the
value of a so the value of a i'm feeding
using this dictionary and i'm saying
that a is equal to 3. now there are
multiple ways of populating the value of
a because it typically this won't be
just a single a scalar value like in
this case right remember scalar so it's
just one value one number typically it
would be a vector or or a tensor very
often it is a tensor so we will see step
by step so we can start with the very
basic example where a can be a scalar so
in this case a is equal to 3 that's what
we are saying feed underscore dict in
this case feed underscore dict is the
name of a variable by the way so you
can't give anything else here so if you
just say feed is equal to this it will
give you an error all right so keep that
in mind either you specify feed
underscore dick is equal to and give the
dictionary pass the dictionary or you
straight away like in this case this is
another format so let's see first let me
execute this it has given 6 okay i think
let me see if i can clear out this
particular cell so it becomes easier to
understand okay so it is giving you 6.
let me do that once again clear out this
and then okay and let me change the
format so this is one way of doing it
another way is you don't even have to
specify the name of this parameter feed
underscore tech you just pass the
dictionary and it will
execute okay but typically this makes
the code readable so that's the reason
most of the places whenever you find
tensorflow code you will see that they
explicitly mention feed underscore date
so that the code is readable otherwise
it can get confusing so i will also
comment this and retain the other format
okay so i hope it's clear so what we are
doing here we are running the operation
b and what exactly is bb is twice a a
into 2. so therefore what we are doing
and a has not been
doesn't have any value out here right so
that's why we are feeding the value of a
and then the operation gets completed so
a gets a value of 3 and then it gets
multiplied by 2 because that's what we
said here therefore b gets a value of 6
and that's what is being fed into result
and that's what is getting printed here
okay now as i mentioned a need not be
just a scalar value it can be a vector
with a multi-dimension
array and so on and so forth so let's
start showing you uh examples of that
again let me just clear out the outputs
let me clear this and let me also clear
this for now okay you can also do before
running up this you could we could also
do clear all output all output clear it
will clear everything but
that will we'll have to start all over
again so i am just doing individually
all right so
in this example we are taking a one
dimension array where rank is equal to 1
and i'm feeding 3 4 5. now let us see
what happens if i run this right as you
can imagine it gets multiplied each
number gets multiplied so the result is
6 8 10 okay now as i said it can get
more complicated now let's say this is a
multi-dimensional vector so if you what
happens if you feed this okay so as you
can see this is pretty complicated no
but if you feed this again all you're
doing is
there is okay there is a slight change
here again you can also
create your dictionary outside and feed
that here you don't have to directly do
it here like in this case you see there
are variations of the exact syntax in
the way you write it right so there is a
slight variation so in this case you are
creating the dictionary straight away
here kind of inline but here you created
the dictionary separately because it is
more complicated and then you are
passing that dictionary here so i said
dictionary is equal to a and then i am
saying this is what should be the value
of a this is and i'm feeding that and
then i'm using directly that dictionary
here okay so this is equivalent to
putting this code here right so if we
execute this what happens same so you
get because a was a let's say this is a
3 by
4 by 2 right so that is one yeah three
by four by two right so you see here
this is a multi-dimensional array so you
feed that and the values you see here
just one two three it became two four
six four five six became eight ten
twelve seven eight 9 became 14 16 18 and
so on and so forth okay i hope now you
got an idea about placeholders and in
real life what happens is you typically
won't create these dictionaries manually
and since this is a
quick demo we did this you will actually
read the data into this dictionary and
then you feed that when you're doing the
computation okay so it could be a csv
file or it could be a image file so
input is basically
read and fed in
usually it is also done in patches so
you don't read the entire thing because
they can be large amount of data so that
is the idea behind having these
placeholders and the way we feed these
placeholders there is a provision there
is a deliberately that has been made a
provision for
this kind of getting data into the
program in chunks okay now in this
particular example we will close the
session here and then i will show you
what is the other way of creating a
session right so now if i close the
session here now if i try to do anything
with the session it will give us an
error so i will probably not do that
right now now there is another way or
another format and this is a very common
way of using the session but i didn't
want to start off with this because this
could get a little confusing the a
simpler way was to create session saying
says is equal to tf.session but
typically you will do it in what is
known as a width block this is a very
common way of creating session so once
you have the graph you would execute the
graph in a session using a width block
and this is the syntax so you say with
df dot session assess all right and then
you put all your code here so what will
happen is you don't have to explicitly
close the session the moment this width
block gets
completed the session gets closed okay
so let's just take a quick look at this
example now if i uh let me clear this
current output we clear okay so this is
the hello world example a little bit
earlier we did that so i'm doing
with tf.session assassin result is equal
to says dot run hello plus world and
then i say print result okay so within
this with block i am doing all my
computation and this gets executed now
let's say i try to run remember i
created a session here now if i want to
let's say do something like run sesh dot
run a it is giving an error because the
session is no longer valid
right so you cannot either you have to
run this if you want to run this you
have to run this in this with block
or you shouldn't have closed the session
here right you remember this we said
session.close so since we have closed
the session there is no
active session therefore it is giving an
error okay now there is a third way
of creating a session but for now i will
skip it because that is very very
specific to the notebooks and and so on
so we will just avoid it you start with
for beginners i think the best way is to
start with creating a separate session
and then writing your code and then
closing your session now of course
remember if you don't do this part says
dot close it will not give any error or
anything like that only thing is that
it's a good practice and your resources
will get released otherwise
if you do multiple of these programs if
they are running then your resources
will get blocked that's the only thing
and to start with it is it is simpler to
do it this way so initially when you're
doing you start with this but as you
move forward as you become familiar with
the tensorflow programming i would
recommend all of you to get into this
model most of the programming tensorflow
programming is done like this with df
dot session ss okay all right so that
was one book or one page of a code that
we have done explaining about variables
constants and placeholders now let me
explain how the graph works so in this
example we are going to see how the
graph is created how the graph gets
executed and so on okay now that we got
a understanding of constants and
variables and placeholders okay so we
will start as usual by importing our
library and as i said whenever you
create a tf or tensorflow object there
will be what is known as a default graph
and you can get a handle of that by
saying get default graph so let's do
that and you can display the operations
remember every node in the graph is
considered as an operation right so as
of now as you can see we have not done
anything we have not created a constant
or variable or nothing right so there
was there is no operation so by the way
let's do one thing let's start with the
all output clear so that
i don't have to again do individually so
i'll just run these two lines of code
okay now so yeah so we have the default
graph and as of now there are no
operations so there is a method called
get underscore operations which will
kind of display
or show what are the various operations
that have been performed on the graph so
as i said to start with they have no
operations being performed so when i try
to display it's empty there are no
nothing is there no operations okay now
let's see what happens when we slowly
step by step start writing or building
the graph so my first step may be to
create a constant okay remember in the
previous example i have shown you how to
create a constant in the most simple or
the simplest way which is like constant
and then the number right now a small
extension of that is you can actually
give a name to your constant now again
this need not be the same i can say a is
equal to name and xyz i can give
anything here okay this is just for your
reference but here for simplicity
because there is a purpose why i am
using the same name as the name of the
variable and there are other reasons as
well why you would give a name again to
a constant or a variable this is again
useful when we are using what is known
as tensorboard otherwise it doesn't have
much value this additional name doesn't
have much value in this our case also we
will be seeing the graph and that's why
i'm using this but otherwise this having
additionally a name usually doesn't add
much value all right so let's create a
constant i created a constant now let us
see what's going on in the graph so i
will just say operations is equal to get
operations and if you see here now
you remember here it was blank now you
see the first operation is showing up
and this a that's the reason i put here
so it is showing as a and it says that
okay you have performed an operation
and there is a constant you have created
a constant okay all right so let's move
on let's say we want to create a second
constant and this is b so if i see what
does what are the operations list of
operations that have been performed you
see here there are two of them so you
have operation a which is a constant
then you have an operation b another
constant you recall we in the term
operation here is not very intuitive
right so we are just creating constants
or numbers or variables and it is saying
it's an operation but that's that's a
terminology in tensorflow everything is
an operation here okay all right so then
what else let's say i want to create a
third operation
and that is basically adding which is
this is a real operation in normal sense
as well so let's say i'm creating c
which is
adding a and b and the c value obviously
will be a plus b
okay now if we want to see what is in c
and we say c you see here it is not
showing 30 it just says it is a tensor
and it is of type in 32 right because
we have not executed the graph we are
still only building the graph i hope
this makes it easy to understand okay so
we are just building the graph we have
till we do remember till we do a session
and run a particular operation
you're not actually executing anything
okay you're just building the graph all
right so now let us see what are the
operations we have done a b and now c so
you will see there are three of them a b
and c okay now let's do one more
operation which is d
and here i am doing multiplication
remember we did a tf dot add now i'll do
tf.multiply and i'm multiplying a and b
and i'm calling this operation as d so a
has
i think
10 and b has 20 so
d will be actually 200 when we execute
it right now it is just a tensor and it
is of shape in 32 okay and once again we
can see what are the operations abcd and
let's do one last operation here which
is e which is once again multiplication
of c and d now that c has 30 which is a
plus b and d has 200 which is a into b
so
now c into d will be 30 into 200 which
is which is equal to
6000 but as we have seen earlier that
multiplication will not happen right now
so now you have built a
fairly simple but operation graph which
consists of
a b c d e one two three four five
operations okay so you built a small
it's not a very complicated one but a
simple graph now you need to execute
these operations so what you need to do
you need to create a session okay so
says dot tf is equal to session and then
you can run these session
print says dot run e now am i missing
something do i have to initialize the
variables that's a question for you
thing can tell me do i have to
initialize the variables that remember i
ran one piece of code i think you must
have got the answer i don't have to
because i am just using
all constants here i have not used any
variable here right so i don't have to
write execute that piece of code to
initialize the variables so i can just
create a session and run any of the
operations that i want to run so in this
case i am running session e operation e
right this operation e now i can
actually run individually instead of
doing directly e i could have run only a
or i could have run b and so on and so
forth but in this case i have run e
which in turn will do all the required
computations which is for example
assigning the value to a and b and c
doing the multiplication and so on all
those operations will be performed which
are required to do the computation of e
okay now there is a small piece of code
that you can use to find out what are
the various operations that are there in
this particular graph in this case of
course it was very easy very
straightforward i have created abcde but
in normal programming in real life this
can sometimes help to see
how
what is there in your graph what kind of
operations are going on in your graph so
you can write this piece of code and it
may sometimes help debugging as well
okay all right so i finished my session
what do we have to do we need to close
the session right because i did not use
the width block so i need to close the
session as a good practice
so i close the section good so that's
how the graph works
i hope it was helpful in understanding
how variables and constants and
placeholders are created in the previous
example we saw and how exactly you
create a graph and then you actually
execute that graph that's the way
tensorflow program works that's the
structure of tensorflow program okay so
now that we understood the structure of
tensorflow programming let's take an
example and a classification example
and
take some real
data from from outside external data csv
file and
try to solve a classification problem
for that let's first go back to the
slides and understand what is the
problem statement and then we will come
back okay so what is the case here we
have some census data and which has all
these features or variables like um the
age of a person
what class work class what is his
education what is his marital status
gender and so on and so forth so there
are a bunch of a bunch of features that
are available and
we have to basically classify or not
classify we have to build a model for
classifying whether the income of this
person
is above 50k or below 50k okay so there
is actually a label data available we
will then try to build a model and then
see what is the accuracy so that this is
a typical machine learning problem
actually but as i said tensorflow can be
used for doing machine learning as well
so we will as a simple example we will
take
machine learning so this is how the high
level the code looks and in tensorflow
programming we also take a help of
regular python libraries like for
example
it could be numpy or it could be
scikit-learn or it could be pandas in
this case and because before you
actually develop or before you train
your model create your model you need to
prepare the data into a certain format
and sometimes if you're doing machine
learning activity you all are familiar
those familiar with machine learning
will know you need to split your data
into training and test data sets so all
that can be done using regular uh
non-tensorflow libraries right so these
are like regular python libraries and
scikit learn and so on so we use that
and then prepare the data and then use
tensorflow for performing either the
machine learning or deep learning
activity now so what is the advantage of
using tensorflow the main advantage is
that tensorflow offers high level apis
right we talked about that so in this
case we will be using i'll explain what
is in the slide but before that i wanted
to just show you what is the api that we
will be using so we will be using the
estimator api we will be using the
estimator api to create a classifier
what is known as a linear classifier now
in order to do that you need to prepare
the data and you need to prepare the
data into a certain structure or format
and the api itself needs to be fed in a
certain way so that is exactly what we
are doing before we get into the regular
tensorflow code okay so these slides
will quickly show you what exactly is
happening but i will take you into
jupiter notebook and run that code and
show you so here we are importing the
data the data is the name of the file is
census underscore data.csv it's a csv
file and then there is
income bracket is one of the columns
which basically is our target that is
what is used that is the label rather
but this doesn't have numeric values so
it has the income so
we need to convert that into binary
values either 0 or 1. so that's what we
are doing here and then we are splitting
using scikit learn we are doing
splitting of the data into test and
training right so this is a standard
scikit-learn people some of you who are
familiar with machine traditional
machine learning and you have done
machine learning in python using
scikit-learn will immediately recognize
this this is a sk learning scikit learn
and there is a readily available method
to split the data into training and test
that's what we are doing here and then
you need to create what is known as
feature columns and input functions
before you can call the api estimator
api that's what we are doing here and
data and also there is there are
different ways of creating the feature
columns for
numeric values and for categorical
values or rather for continuous values
and categorical values okay so that's
what has been
two types we are doing here
we will see again in the code as well
and
then you create your model so this is
basically model is equal to df dot
estimator linear classifier and then
you're feeding the feature columns and
also subsequently you will call the
training by passing the input function
and you specify how many iterations to
be done for the training process and
again this is all typical machine
learning process so there is nothing
specific for tensorflow here and then
you evaluate your model because this is
classification model so you can again
take help of the scikit-learn to test
the accuracy and get the reports
evaluation perform the evaluation and
get the report like this one right so
this is the classification report and
you will see what is the precision
recall f1 score and so on again this is
a standard machine learning process all
right so that's pretty much as far as
the code here is concerned once again
let me take you into our
lab and
we will get started with this particular
code now let me clear out the outputs so
that you can step by step you can see
the output so this is our data and um we
will actually be this is just a display
here the code starts from here so before
when we start with our tensorflow part
of it as i mentioned we now remember in
the previous examples the data was kind
of cooked up internally we created some
data and we were using it right the
constants variables and so on here is a
real life example so you are actually
getting data from outside so you know
before we get into tensorflow this is
actually regular python code so we are
using pandas for example to create our
data frame so we will import pandas and
then we will basically read our file
into a pandas data frame and this is how
the data
looks right and if you do a head it will
give you about six
readings or observations five or six
observations and then you can take a
look at how your data is looking so for
example you have age work class
education and so on and so forth and you
see here this last column income
underscore bracket it says whether the
income is greater than 50k or less than
50k so this cannot be
understood or this cannot be fed into
our
model or
you know so that's the reason we need to
convert this this will not be understood
right so this needs to be converted
saying okay
maybe less than 50 k is 0 and greater
than 50 k is 1 so that conversion needs
to be done before we feed it into our
model so that's what we are going to do
as we move forward so this is the code
for doing that okay so we take this and
then
we define a function
and then we run that function so now we
have wherever it is
less than 50k it will have 0 and greater
than 50k it will have 1. so we have now
updated the data then the next part is
to split our data into training and
test data set so how are we going to do
that we again will take the standard
python library which is scikit-learn sql
on library and
we use an existing
function there which is a train test
split and what we are doing here is
basically splitting the data into i'm
sorry i need to run this
and then this
okay sorry about that so
once i run this what is what are we
doing here again those are familiar with
scikit learn will immediately recognize
i am splitting this into test and train
i'm saying test size is 30 percent so 30
of the data should go into test and
training should have seventy percent
okay so that's all we are doing point
three indicates thirty percent so you
can again this can be individual
preferences some people do it like fifty
fifty some people twenty eighty and in
our case we are doing uh 70 30. so
training is 70 and test is 30. okay all
right so
we have so far we've been doing regular
non-tensorflow stuff so preparing the
data so that we can now use for
tensorflow and in tensorflow what we are
doing is we will be using the api called
estimator now estimator in order to call
estimator you need to prepare what is
known as feature columns so feature
columns have to be in a certain format
basically it is nothing but the columns
we have to put them in a certain format
and then when we are calling the the
training we need to pass what is known
as an input function again a certain way
in which you need to pass that function
so that is what we need to do before we
create the model and
run the model for training so the next
few lines will be doing that quick look
at before we even get in once again into
the tensorflow code so this is just
showing us what are the various columns
names of the columns of this data okay
so that is what is shown here and this
is more for when i was writing the code
i could copy paste from here that's the
reason i this line of code is there
instead of typing in these values okay
good so now is where
the actual tensorflow action starts so i
import tensorflow and now i will use
this feature column functionality to
create my feature columns
and there is a certain construct how you
create the feature columns again
probably the details of that is out of
scope here but just that you need to
know that we need to create feature
columns and the way you create feature
columns for continuous values and for
categorical values is slightly different
and that's the reason you have two
different blocks okay so for categorical
values you need to use what is known as
tf dot feature column dot categorical
column with vocabulary list and again
within this again there are two ways in
which you can create for categorical
values one is a vocabulary list where
you know
how many types are there so for example
gender column can have only male and
female so in such a case there are let's
say a finite number of values for a
given
column then you use a column with
vocabulary list okay so and then you say
what is the name of the column and what
are the possible values so in this case
male and female now there will be
situations where the the values that
this column can have
okay first of all it is a categorical
column that means it can have names or
some non-numerical values but the number
of values is probably unknown or
undefined so for example occupation now
occupation can have any value it can be
self-employed it can be a software
professional bank
a teacher doctor so so many
possibilities are there and we don't
know in the given data how many
occupations have been listed right so
that is where you use what is known as
categorical column with hash bucket and
you specify the hash bucket size so what
it what this says is there can be a
maximum of thousand such values so
typically if you give a safe number
safely large number so that you don't
run out of these number of occupations
so i think thousand is a safe number i
don't think there will be more than
thousand occupations in a given data so
that's the idea behind it but that's a
judgment call we need to take what
should be the size of this bucket size
right hash bucket size so these are two
different types for categorical values
for creating the feature column so we
will execute this for all the
categorical columns obviously you need
to know the type of the columns and that
is where if you see right at the
beginning this information was provided
what is the data type and you see here
the column name and what whether it is
continuous or categorical this
information is provided in the census
data wherever we pick this census data
from by the way this was picked from
online from a government website and we
stored locally so on that website it is
mentioned the details of this data were
mentioned and they have mentioned
whether each of these columns is
categorical or continuous so that
information we have to use and we have
to create feature columns using this
categorical
method for the categorical type of
columns and then for numeric or
continuous values you just use
what is known as feature column dot
numeric column okay so these are all
continuous or numeric values like age
education number capital gain capital
loss hours per word these are all
numerical values or continuous values
right so you just say tf dot feature
underscore column dot numeric underscore
column and then give the name of the
column so once you do that i think i
have executed the previous one yeah this
one now so your feature columns are
ready and uh you need to basically
create a vector of all these columns and
we call that as feet underscore calls
which is which is like a short form for
feature columns now as you have seen
i've mentioned earlier also there are
two things that are needed one is the
feature columns and another is the input
function so feature columns to first
create the model and then to train the
model you need to create an input
function so now we have the feature
columns ready next is to create an input
function and there is a certain way in
which you need to
this construct is pretty much very
common construct so we will use that so
the input function takes these x and y
values for training and tests you
remember these are the x strain is the x
values of the training data set and y
train is the labels of the training data
set so that's what we are using here x
train y train and then we specify what
is the batch size batch size you
remember i mentioned this is what will
say how many records need to be read
each time right so typically in when we
are doing the training process we don't
get the entire data in one shot we do it
in batches so what size you specify here
number of epochs in this case we just
say none but number of epochs is again
probably the definition is not required
here but at a very high level how many
times the entire data has to be passed
through the model right so if you have
thousand records and you pass all the
thousand records three times for
training purpose then you call that as
three epochs right so there is a
difference between the batch size and
epochs so when let's say we have
thousand records and you're saying batch
size is 100 that means there will be 10
batches right so if you take 10 batches
then that is one epoch gets completed
okay then you the training obviously
doesn't get completed in one round okay
so you need to pass this data again
maybe a second time or a third time till
you get the right accuracy that is known
as epochs okay again if you need more
details about this you may have to go
through the machine learning tutorial i
think it becomes much clearer okay so
you have your input function as well
let's execute that okay and now we are
ready to create the use the api right so
what will we do we will create the
linear classifier using
tf.estimator.linearclassifier
and this guy needs feature columns right
so that's why we created we did all that
so much of manipulations to create this
feature columns so we have feature
columns so we pass that and we create
our model there may be a few warnings
don't worry about that so we will just
ignore that and now we use that model
and we actually what we did is we
created an instance of the model we have
not really run anything we just created
a instance of the model now we will
create the node for training so
model.train and this needs the input
function remember we we created the
input function so we need to pass the
input function and then we say
the steps is now telling how many
iterations this training
has to be run so we are saying 5000 and
this may be it will probably take a
little long so we will okay but that's
fine i think we will leave it 5000.
sometimes if you have probably a less
powerful machine you can cut it down to
maybe thousand or something like that
but in this case i have a fairly
powerful system so i think it shouldn't
take much long
let's
go ahead and give couple of minutes for
it to get over okay so let us go back
yeah i think this is done you see here
the the hourglass has
disappeared that means this computation
is done yes okay this is done right
saving checkpoint for 5000 that means it
is done so training is done so now what
we have to do we need to do the
evaluation so
again this is a standard machine
learning method so
methodology rather so training has been
done with the training data set now you
need to evaluate using your test data
set so that's what we are doing here for
example you see here x underscore test
is your the test data set remember we
used scikit-learn to split the data into
training and test data set so x
underscore test and a quick question why
are we not using y underscore test here
like we did in case of uh training
obviously we are expecting the model to
predict the values y values right so
that's why we don't pass the y values
here all right so let's execute this for
doing the evaluation all right and then
we
put them in a proper format because the
output doesn't come out in a proper
format so we put it in a lisp format and
then we can just check yeah so this is
done and
we can check what is the first element
in this what is the probabilities and so
on so it's just
a quick way to see if the values are
there or not you can take any value here
right any element here all right now
that the testing is done what we need to
do again we will probably put them in
some kind of this is more of a
formatting thing we will just uh
run through quickly and then we will use
once again scikit-learn for finding out
the accuracy and so on because
scikit-learn offers what is known as a
classification report functionality so
we will use that and find out how well
our model has performed so you see here
again people with
machine learning background will be
immediately able to recognize this so it
gives us what is the precision what is
the recall
and f1 score uh this is pretty much like
you're getting like almost 85 percent
accuracy which is pretty okay and
there are other ways to increase the
accuracy for example you can run the
training for more iterations that is one
way get more data and so on and so forth
or use
this is a linear classifier we could you
have used a non-linear classifier and so
on so again multiple ways of doing it to
increase the accuracy but the idea here
was to quickly show you a piece of
tensorflow code and that's what we have
done here we had the original tensorflow
release of 1.0 and then they came out
with the 2.0 version and the 2.0
addressed so many things out there that
the 1.0 really needed so we start
talking about tensorflow 1.0 versus 2.0
i guess you would need to know this for
a legacy programming job if you're
pulling apart somebody else's code the
first thing is that tensorflow 2.0
supports eager execution by default it
allows you to build your models and run
them instantly and you can see here from
tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2
we have
almost double the code to do the same
thing so if i want to do with tf.session
or tensorflow session as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit
x train y train and then your validation
data your x value y value and your epics
and your batch size all that goes into
the fit
and you can see here where that was all
just compressed to make it run easier
you can just create a model and do a fit
on it and you only have like that last
set of code on there so it's automatic
that's what they mean by the eager so if
you see the first part you're like what
the heck is all the session thing going
on that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when
you get into 2.0 it's just nice and
clean
if you remember from the beginning i
said cross
on our list up there and across is the
high level api in tensorflow 2.0
cross is the official high level api of
tensorflow 2.0 it has incorporated cross
as tf.cross cross provides a number of
model building apis such as sequential
functional and subclassing so you can
choose the right level of abstraction
for your project and
we'll hopefully touch base a little bit
more on this sequential being the most
common uh form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other
so everything's going in a sequential
order
functional
is where you can split the layer so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together
and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or a neural basic
reverse propagation neural network and
then those all come together into
another layer which is your
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing
is the most complicated as you're
building your own models and you can
subclass your own models into cross so
very powerful tools here this is all the
stuff that's been coming out currently
in the tensorflow cross setup a third
big change we're going to look at is it
in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use tf layers as variables
you would have to write tf variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers
of course this changes a little bit as
the more complicated
tensor you have coming in but all of
it's very easy to do and that's what 2.0
does a really good job of and here we
have um
a little bit more on the scope of this
and you can see how tensorflow 1 asks
you to do
these different layers and values if you
look at the scope and the default name
you start looking at all the different
code in there to create the variable
scope that's not even necessary in
tensorf 2.0 so you'd have to do one
before you do do what you see the code
in 2.0 in 2.0 you just create your model
it's a sequential model and then you can
add all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our api cleanup and
the autograph
uh in the api cleanup tensorflow 1 you
could build models using tf gans tf app
tf contrib tf flags etc in tensorflow 2
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
tf app your tf flags your tf logging are
all gone
so there's those are three legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our tf function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow 1
0 the python functions were limited and
could not be compiled or exported
re-imported
so you were continually having to redo
your code you couldn't very easily just
put a pointer to it and say hey let's
reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the tf function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of tf
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph a graph is not a picture of a
person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things
graph is what are all those lines that
are connecting different objects
so if you remember from before where we
had the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using
in neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented api so this is
what you're working with you have your
tf cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your tf layers tf losses
tf metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross
running your estimators and then being
able to swap in different layers you can
your losses your metrics all of that is
so built into tensorflow makes it really
easy to use and then you can get down to
your low level tf api
you have extensive control over this you
can put your own formulas in there your
own procedures or models in there
you could have it split we talked about
that earlier so with the 2.0 you can now
have it split one direction we do a
linear regression model and then go to
the other where it does a
neural network and maybe each neural
network has a different activation set
on it and then it comes together into
another layer which is another neural
network so you can build these really
complicated models and at the low level
you can put in your own apis you can
move that stuff around and most recently
we have the tf code can run on multiple
platforms
and so you have your cpu
which is
basically like in the computer i'm
running on i have
eight cores and 16 dedicated threads i
hear they now have one out there that
has over 100 cores
so you have your cpu running and then
you have your gpu which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
tpu setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models
neural network kind of set up
so now you can export the tf code and it
can run on all kinds of different
platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture uh we
have
you can see on the left this is usually
where you start out with and 80 of your
time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right
so the first level in tensorflow is
going to be your read and pre-processed
data your tf data feature columns
this is going to feed into your tf cross
or your pre-made estimators
and kind of you have your tensorflow hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that set up you have your distribution
strategy where are you gonna run it
you're gonna be running it on just your
regular cpu are you gonna be running it
with the gpu added in um like i have a
pretty high-end graphics card so it
actually grabs that gpu processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized tpu
setup in there that you paid extra money
for
it could be if you're in later on when
you're distributing the package you
might need to run this on some really
high processors because you're
processing at a server level for
uh let's say net you might be processing
this at a
distribute you're distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done
every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a
to give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for
data fraud analysis working with the
banks you want to be able to run this at
a high speed so that when you have
hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person and probably has
their credit card so when we're talking
about all those fun things we're talking
about saved model this is we were
talking about that earlier where it used
to be when you did one of these models
it wouldn't truncate the float numbers
the same and so a model going from one
you build the model on your
machine in the office and then you need
to distribute it and so we have our
tensorflow serving cloud on premium
that's what i was talking about if
you're like a banking or something like
that
now they have tensorflow lite so you can
actually run a tensorflow on an android
or an ios or raspberry pi a little
breakout board there in fact they just
came out with a new one that has a
built-in there's this little mini tpu
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that
talking about an affordable way to beta
test a new product you have the
tensorflow js which is for browser and
node server so you can get that out on
the browser for some simple computations
that don't require a lot of heavy
lifting but you want to distribute to a
lot of endpoints and now they also have
other language bindings so you can now
create your tensorflow backend save it
and have it accessed from c java go
c sharp rust r or from whatever package
you're working on so we kind of have an
overview of the architecture and what's
going on behind the scenes and in this
case what's going on as far as
distributing it let's go ahead and take
a look at
three specific pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions
so very basic things you need to know
and understand when you're working with
the tensorflow setup so constants in
tensorflow in tensorflow constants are
created using the function constant in
other words they're going to stay static
the whole time whatever you're working
with the syntax for constant
value d type 9 shape equals none name
constant verify shape equals false
that's kind of the syntax you're looking
at and we'll explore this with our hands
on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do z equals t f
dot constant 5.2 name equals x uh d type
is a float that means that we're never
going to change that 5.2 it's going to
be a constant value and then we have our
variables in tensorflow variables in
tensorflow are in memory buffers that
store tensors
and so we can declare a two by three
tensor populated by ones you could also
do constants this way by the way so you
can create a an array of ones for your
constants i'm not sure why you'd do that
but you know you might need that for
some reason
in here we have v equals tf.variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.ones
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice 2x3
array that's filled with ones and then
of course you can go in there and
they're variables so you can change them
it's a tensor so you have full control
over that and then you of course have
sessions in tensorflow a session in
tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes
and remember when we're talking a graph
or graph x we're talking about all that
information then goes through all those
arrows and whatever computations they
have that take it to the next node and
you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as tf if we do x
equals a tf.constant of 10
we do y equals a tf constant of 2.0 or
20.0 and then you can do z equals
tf.variable
and it's a tf dot add x comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your tf
global variables initializer with tf
session as session
you can do a session run init
and then you print the session run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today i'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then i'll use specifically the jupiter
notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook
the jupiter lab which is just the
jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with jupiter notebook
pie charm uh whatever it is you're going
to use in here you have your spider and
your qt console for different
programming environments the thing to
note
is kind of hard to see but i have my
main
pi 36 right now when i was writing this
tensorflow works in python version 3.6
if you have python version 37 or 3 8
you're probably going to get some errors
in there
might be that they've already updated
and i don't know it now you have an
older version
but you want to make sure you're in
python version 36 in your environment
and of course in anaconda i can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and
pip in your tensorflow or if you're in
anaconda you can do a conda install
tensorflow to make sure it's in your
package
so let's just go ahead and dive in and
bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
i just love the fact i can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what i'm working
on making it really easy to just
demo for the right size go under new
let's go ahead and create a new python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it untitled
let's go ahead and import import
tensorflow as tf
uh at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick
no errors yay no errors i
i do that whenever i do my imports
because i unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
uh or something along those lines so
it's always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know
what version we're working with and we
can do that simply by
using the version command in tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the tf
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and
you know it always confuses me because
sometimes you do tf.version for one
thing you do tf.underscore version
underscore for another thing
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and i did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array
a equals tf.constant
and we're just going to put the array
right in there 4361.
we can run this and now that is what a
is equal to and if we want to just
double check that remember we're in
jupiter notebook where i can just put
the letter a
and it knows that that's going to be
print
otherwise you'd surround it in print and
you can see it's a tf tensor it has the
shape the type and the and the array on
here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
and create a variable and this is also
going to be a two by two array and if we
go ahead and print the v out we'll run
that
uh and sure enough there's our tf
variable in here
uh then we can also let's just go back
up here and add this in here
um i could create another tensor and
we'll make it a constant this time
and we're going to put that in over here
uh we'll have b tf constant
and if we go and print out v and b
i'm going to run that
and this is an interesting thing that
always that happens in here you'll see
right here when i print them both out
what happens is it only prints the last
one unless you use print commands so
important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and surround v with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have
we have the three one five two which is
a variable
and this is just a flat
constant so it comes up as a tf tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a tf variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing i want you to notice is
in variable we capitalize the v and with
the constant we have a lowercase c
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work
uh so those are a couple little things
to note in here and just like any other
array in math
we can do like a concatenate or
concatenate the different values here
and you can see we can take a b
concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axis on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out
you'll see right here we end up with a
tensor so it's put it in as a constant
not as a variable
and you have your array four three seven
eight and six one four five it's
concatenated the two together and again
i wanna highlight a couple things on
this our axes equals one this means
we're doing the columns
so if you had a longer array like right
now we have an array that is like you
know has a shape one whatever it is two
comma two
um axes
zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows
if we had a shape let me just put the
word shape here
um
so you know what i'm talking about it's
very clear and this is i'll tell you
what i spent a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction i'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axes
axis 1 0 1 2 that's going to be our
columns
and if you can do columns then we also
can do rows and that is simply just
changing the concatenate
we'll just grab this one here and copy
it we'll do the whole thing over
ctrl copy
ctrl v and changes from axes one
to axis zero and if we run that uh
you'll see that now we concatenate by
row as opposed to column and you have
four three six one seven eight four
seven so it just brings it right down
and turns it into rows versus columns
you can see the difference there your
output this really you want to look at
the output sometimes just to make sure
your eyes are looking at it correctly
and it's in the format i find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than
understanding
what's going on because conceptually
your mind just just too many dimensions
sometimes
the second thing i want you to notice is
this says a numpy array uh so tensorflow
is utilizing numpy as part of their
format as far as python is concerned
and so you can treat you can treat this
output like a numpy array because it is
just that it's going to be a numpy array
another thing that comes up
more than you would think is filling
one of these with zeros or ones and so
you can see here we just create a tensor
tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer
and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
jupiter so i just type out tensor and i
run this you can see i have a nice
array of the shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things i want to
highlight here is integer 32. if i go to
the
tensorflow data types i want you to
notice how
we have float 16 float 32 float 64
complex if we scroll down you'll see the
integer down here 32 the reason for this
is that we want to control how many bits
are used in the precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform so what would happen is i might
run it on this computer where python
goes does a float to indefinite however
long it wants to
and then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a tf float 16 in
this case we did an integer 32
we could also do this as a float
so if i run this as a float 32
that means this has a 32 32-bit
precision you'll see zero point whatever
and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would i
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor
usually we initiate a lot of this stuff
with random numbers because it does a
better job solving it if you start with
a uniform
set of ones or zeros you're dealing with
a lot of bias so be very careful about
starting a neural network
for one of your rows or something like
that with ones and zeros
on the other hand
i use this for masking you can do a lot
of work with masking you can also have
it might be that
one tenser row is masked
you know zero is is false one is true or
whatever you want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general
you see zeros and ones you usually are
talking about a mask over another array
and just like in numpy you can also
do reshapes so if we take our remember
this is shaped three comma four
maybe we wanna swap that to four comma
three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
ctrl v
let me run that
and you'll see that the the order of
these is now switched instead of four
across now we have three across and four
down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones
and i'm going to change the ones to
tf.random
uniform uh and we'll go ahead and just
take off well we'll go and leave that
i'm going to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441
and this way you can actually see how
the reshape looks a lot different
0.041.15.71
and then instead of having this one it
rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what i was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random dot uniform is one of
the ways to do that now i just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types
one of the things that comes up of
course is
recasting your data
so if we have a d type float 32 we might
want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
i know one of the projects i've worked
on
ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
round it off to a dollar amount so we
only wanted two decimal points
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by a
hundred and then round it off or
whatever you want to do there's a lot or
then convert it to an integer was one
way to round it off
uh kind of
a cheap and dirty trick
uh so we can take this and we can take
this same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
um as an integer and so we're going to
take this tensor we're going to tf.cast
it and if we print
tensor
and then we're going to go ahead and
print
our
tensor
let me just
do a quick copy and paste and when i'm
actually programming i usually type out
a lot of my stuff just to double check
it
in doing a demo
copy and paste works fine but sometimes
be aware that copy and paste can copy
the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what i'm
working on
and you can see here we took
a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it just
converts it right down to a integer
value
sorry integer 32 set up and
remember we talked about
a little bit about reshape
as far as flipping it and i just did
four comma three on the reshape up here
and we talked about axes zero axis one
uh one of the things that is important
to be able to do is to take one of these
variables we'll just take this last one
tensor as integer
and i want to go ahead and transpose it
and so i can do
we'll do a
equals tf.transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if i print the a out and we run
this
you'll see that's the same array but
we've flipped it so that our columns and
rows are flipped this is
the same as reshaping uh so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is if you look at
the numbers the columns
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of rolled down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
uh so we come down here it's all done
for you and so there are so many times
you have to transpose
your digits that this is important to
know that you can just do that you can
flip your rows and columns rather
quickly here and just like numpy you can
also do multiple your different math
functions we'll look at multiplication
and so we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors uh we'll go
ahead and create a
as a constant 5839
and we'll put in a vector v four comma
two and we could have done this where
they matched where this was a two by two
array
but instead
we're going to do just a two by one
array and the code for that is your
tf.matt
mole
so matrix multiplier and we have a times
v and if we go ahead and run this up
let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen the matrix math
this is
5 times 4 plus 8 times 2
3 times 4 plus 9 times 2
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now i know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the matrix or your matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as computing
different models or linear regression
stuff like that
one of the things
is to note is that just like in
numpy you have all of your different
math so we have our tf math
and if we go in here we have
functions we have our cosines absolute
angle all of that's in here so all of
these
are available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull
um oh let's do some multiplication
that's always good we'll stick with our
av
our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bit wise
multiplication and we'll create an av
which is a times b let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here uh we
have the four two and the five eight
three nine and it produces uh 2032 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times
five is 20 4 times 8 is
32 that's where those numbers come from
now we can also quickly create an
identity matrix
which is basically um your main values
on the diagonal being ones and zeros
across the other side
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what that
looks like and we can do let's do
this so we're going to get the shape
this is a simple way very similar to
your numpy you can do a dot shape and
it's going to return a tuple in this
case our rows and columns and so we can
do a quick
print
we'll do rows
oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this
you can see we have three rows
two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity matrix
the scripts
the script for that
got a wrong button there the script for
that looks like this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and d type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions
so we're going to move on to a more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use for that
let's go back and create a
new setup
and we'll go in here new python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because i like to do that
hopefully you made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you've got your math
equations and different things that go
into them
we're going to start building a full
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how
kara sits on top of it and the different
aspects of how it works
the first thing we want to do is we're
going to go and do a lot of imports uh
date times warning scipy scipy is your
math so the back end scientific math uh
warnings because
whenever we do a lot of this you have
older versions newer versions um and so
sometimes when you get warnings you want
to go ahead and just suppress them
we'll talk about that if it comes up on
this particular setup and of course date
time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as pd
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with
seaborn for our graphics and the
seaborne as sns is going to be set on
top of our matplot library which we
import as mpl and then of course we're
going to import our matplot library pi
plot as plt and right off the bat we're
going to set some graphic colors um
patch force edge color equals true
the style we're going to use the 538
style you can look this all up there's
when you get into matplot library and to
seaborn there are so many options in
here it's just kind of nice to make it
look pretty when we start the um
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our
mplrc we're going to put a patch ed
color dim gray line width again this is
all part of our graphics here in our
setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell
node interactivity equals last
expression
here we are pd for pandas options
display max columns so we don't want to
display more than 50.
and then our matplot library is going to
be inline this is a jupiter notebook
thing the matplot library inline
then warnings we're going to filter our
warnings and we're just going to ignore
warnings that way when they come up we
don't have to worry about them
not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import
our specific packages
that we're going to be working with
which is under cross now remember cross
kind of sits on tensorflow so when we're
importing cross and the sequential model
we are in effect importing
tensorflow underneath of it
we just brought in the math probably
should have put that up above and then
we have our cross models we're going to
import sequential now if you remember
from our
slide there was three different options
let me just flip back over there so we
can have a quick
recall on that and so in cross uh we
have sequential functional and
subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have a sequential where it's going
one tensorflow layer at a time you go
kind of look at think of it as going
from left to right or top to bottom or
whatever direction it's going in but it
goes in one direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor
all those kinds of things and then
subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional
but we're running a sequential
tensorflow and that's what this first
import is here we want to bring in our
sequential and then we have our layers
and let's talk a little bit about these
layers this is where cross and
tensorflow
really are happening this is what makes
them so nice to work with is all these
layers are pre-built
so from cross we have layers import
dense
from cross layers import lstm
when we talk about these layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers
the dense layer is your standard neural
network
by default it uses relu for its
activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
cross and we look at their layers this
is across website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in
we can get down here and we can look at
let's see here we have our layer
activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer weights
there's a lot of stuff in here we had
the relu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers
and our dense layers you have an input
layer a dense layer and then we've added
a more customized one with the long-term
short-term memory layer and of course
you can even do your own custom layers
in cross there's a whole functionality
in there for doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do
this is white cross is so popular it's
open source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer
and the long short term memory layer
and then of course from
sk learn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scalar for pre editing
our
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv
and let's go ahead and take a quick look
at that this is in openoffice it's just
a standard you know might be do excel
whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
a number of columns
number of rows it actually goes down to
like 8 000.
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row
is kind of just a random number put in
going down
probably not something we're going to
work with
the second row
is
bendung
i'm guessing that's a reference for the
profile
if we scroll to the bottom which i'm not
going to do because it takes forever to
get back up they're all the same
the same thing with the status the
status is the same
we have a date so we have a sequential
order here
here is the jam which i'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our o3 co no2 reading so2 no co2
voc
and then some other numbers here pm1 pm
2.5 pm 4 pm 10
without actually
looking through the data i mean some of
this i can guess is like temperature
humidity i'm not sure what the pms are
but we have a whole slew of data here so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area in a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so code wise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame df is a nice abbreviation commonly
used for data frames
equals pd.read csv and then our the path
to it just happens to be on my d drive
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in jupiter i can take this and go
the other way
make it real small so you can see all
the columns going across and we get a
full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the ben dung
the
date we have a time stamp
our o3 count co and so forth on here
and this is just your basic
pandas printing out the top five rows we
could easily have done uh three rows
uh five rows ten whatever you want to
put in there by default that's uh five
for pandas now i talk about this all the
time so i know i've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together
so we want to go ahead and start with
our
date time it's come in in two columns
we have our date here and we have our
time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're building
our we're going to submit our
pandas data frame and the tab name when
we go ahead and do this
uh that's all of our information that we
want to go ahead and create
and then goes for i in range df
shape 0.
so we're going to go through the whole
setup and we're going to list tab append
df location i
and here is our date going in there and
then return the numpy array list tab d
type date time 64. that's all we're
doing we're just switching this to a
date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do df datetime equals combined datetime
and then i always like to
print we'll do df head
just to see what that looks like
and so we come out of this
we now have our setup on here and of
course it's edited on to the far right
here's our date time you can see the
formats changed
so there's our we've added in the date
time column and we've brought the date
over and we've taken this format here
and it's an actual variable with a 0 0 0
on here well that doesn't look good so
we need to also include the time part of
this and we want to convert it into
hourly data
so let's go ahead and do that
uh to do that uh to finish combining our
date time let's go ahead and create a a
little
script here to combine the time in there
same thing we just did we're just
creating a numpy array returning a numpy
array and cr forcing this into a date
time format and we can actually spend
hours just going through uh these
conversions how do you
pull it from the pandas data frame
how do you set it up
so i'm kind of skipping through it a
little fast because i want to stay
focused on tensorflow and cross
keep in mind this is like 80 of your
coding when you're doing a lot of this
stuff is going to be reformatting these
things resetting them back up
so that it looks right on here and you
know it just takes time to get through
all that but that is usually what the
companies are paying you for that's what
the big
bucks are for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
now remember we can select from df are
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped
a couple of the columns those ones i
showed you earlier they're just
repetitive data so there's nothing in
there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the df head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see what we're talking about
uh we have now reorganized this so we
put in date time
03 co
so now this is in the same order
as it was before and you'll see the date
time
now has our 0 0
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together
so there's a lot more manageable and in
the format we want and in the right
sequential order
and if we go back to
there we go our air quality
you can see right here we're looking at
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own
date time column we can get rid of those
these are the different columns of
information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist
first thing i want to do is get a
description what am i looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
uh minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there
so you can get a quick look at a glance
describing the data or descriptive
analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable
we're going to look at a number of
things for each variable
and we'll see right here q1
we can simply do the quantile 0.25
percent
which should match um our 25 up here and
we'll be looking at the min the max
and we're just going to do this is
basically we're breaking this down for
each uh different
variable in there
one of the things that's kind of fun to
do
we're going to look at that in just a
second let me get put the next piece of
code in here um
clean out some of our
we're going to drop a couple things our
last rows and first row because those
have
usually have a lot of null values and
the first row is just our titles so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles
again it's it's the same you know we're
still looking at the 25
quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows
we're going to go ahead and go through
all of our columns and this way we can
look at each
column individually and so we'll
just create a q1 q3 min max min iqr max
iqr and calculate the quantile of i of
df2
we're basically doing
the math that they did up here but we're
splitting it apart
that's all this is
and
this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual
if this was my own project i would
probably spend days and days going
through
what these different values mean
one of the biggest
data science
things we can look at that's important
is uh
use your use your common sense
you know if you're looking at this data
and it doesn't make sense and you go
back in there and you're like wait a
minute what the heck did i just do
at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on
now
we're looking at this and you can see
right here here's our attribute for our
o3 so we've broken it down
we have our q1 5.88 q3 10.37 if we go
back up here here's our 5 8 we've
rounded it off
10.37 is in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our max iqr and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times iqr and the iqr is your q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters and
this is all
data science
as far as the hard math
we're really not we're actually trying
to focus on cross and tensorflow you
still got to go through all this stuff i
told you 80
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck
happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum iqr
that means something's going wrong there
and it usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the min
minimum iqr it's an outlier and if the
max value is greater than the
max iqr we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outliers found
minimum value high outliers found
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know uh crime detection what are we
looking for we're looking for the
outliers what doesn't fit a normal
business deal and then we'll go ahead
and throw in
just threw in a lot of code oh my
goodness uh so we have if your max is
greater than iqr print outlier is found
what we want to do is we want to start
cleaning up these outliers and so we
want to convert
we'll do create a convert nand
x max iqr equals max
underscore iqr min iqr equals mini qr so
this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in python and if x is greater than the
max iqr and x is less than the min iqr x
equals uh null we're going to set it to
null why because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that series so you can look at just the
outlier and then we're going to convert
the nand hum again we have x
max iqr is 100 percent min iqr is min
iqr
if x is greater than max iqr and x is
less than mini qr again we're going to
return a null value otherwise it's going
to remain the same value x x equals x
and you can see as we go through the
code if i equals
our hum
then we go ahead and do this
that's a column specific to humidity
that's your hum column
uh then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the
run a map on there and convert the non
h2m
uh you can see here it's this is just
cleanup uh we run we found out that
humidity probably has some weird values
in it
we have our outliers
that's all this is
and so when we go ahead and finish this
and we take a look at our outliers and
we run this code here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier
99.06
outliers have been interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like
these sensors coming in
they probably have a failed sensor in
there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then
converting it over and setting it up
method linear
so we interpolate left linears it's
going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
we run through this you can see down
here that we have our
outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data
how do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on let's take the temp value
and we're going to go ahead and and use
a logarithmic function on the temp value
and uh
it's interesting because it's like how
do you how do you heck do you even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific
we're talking about being an expert in
air care i'm not an expert in air care
um you know it's not what i go look at i
don't look at air care data in fact this
is probably the first air care data set
up i've looked at but the experts come
in there and they come to you and say
hey in data science this is a
exponentially variable variable on here
so we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts
data analytics a lot of times you're
talking about somebody who is a data
analysis might be all the way usually a
phd level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey
domain air care
this needs to be this is a skew because
the data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
we have our
uh we'll do a distribution df
we'll create another data frame from the
temp values and then from a data set
from the log temp so we can put them
side by side and we'll just go ahead and
do a quick histogram and this is kind of
nice plot of figure figure size here's
our plt from matplot library
and then we'll just do a distribution
underscore df there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas and this is a chart you would
send back to your data analysis and say
hey is this what you wanted this is how
the data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing i note
is we've gone from a 10
20 30 scales a 2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here
we'll go ahead and split our data up
and this of course is any good data
scientists
you want to have a training set and a
test set
and we'll go ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error
and we'll have our train size of 75
percent and the test size is going to be
of course the train size minus the
length of the data set and then we can
simply do train comma test
here's our data set which is going to be
the train size the test size
uh and then if we go and print this let
me just go ahead and run this we can see
how these values
split it's a nice split of 1298 and then
433 points of value
they're going to be for our
setup on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
um that was from up here that's what we
called the
logarithmic
value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh convert an array of
values into a data set matrix we're
going to create a little
setup in here we create our data set our
data set's going to come in we're going
to do a look back of one so we're going
to look back one piece of data going
backward
and we have our data x and our data y
for i and range length of data set look
back -1
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data
and take a look at the shape of it let
me go ahead and just put that code in
here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our train x our train y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go
and we run this piece of code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of x
1296 comma 1
shape of y train y
test x text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the x comes in
and we're only having a single value at
out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um what
we're going to train the data with is
yesterday's data yesterday says hey the
humidity was at
97 percent what should today's humidity
be at if it's 97 yesterday is it going
to go up or is it going to go down today
of 97 does it go up to 100 what's going
on there uh and so our we're looking
forward to the next piece of data which
says hey tomorrow's is going to you know
today's community is this this is what
tomorrow's humidity is going to be
that's all that is all that is is
stacking our data so that
our y is basically
x plus 1 or x could be y minus 1.
and then a couple things to note is our
x data um we're only dealing with the
one column but you need to have it in a
shape that has it by the columns so you
have the two different numbers and since
we're doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here
now this is going to run into a problem
and the reason is is that we have what
they call a time step
and the time step is that long term
short term memory layer
so we're going to add another reshape on
here let me just go down here and put it
into the next cell
and so we want to reshape the input
array in the form of sample time step
features
we're only looking at one feature
and i mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am i getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on
uh so we're going to do is we're going
to add one more uh level on here instead
of being 12.99 one we want to go one
more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 1299
we added the one dimension and then we
have our train x shape one
and this could have depends again on how
far back in the long short term memory
you want to go
that is what that piece of code is for
and that reshape is and you can see the
new shape is now one
1299 one one
versus the 1299 one and then the other
part of the shape 432 one one again this
is our tr our x in and of course our
test x and then our y is just a single
column because we're just doing one
output that we're looking for
so now we've done our eighty percent um
you know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit
the lstm neural network uh and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model and we'll do this
sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order
that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
layer two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together
we're doing just sequential on here and
then we decided to do the long short
term memory
and we have our input shape
which it comes in again this is what all
this switching was we could have easily
made this one two three or four going
back as far as the end number on there
we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck
is this model coming from
what kind of models do we have available
and
there's let me go and put the next model
in there
because we're going to do two models and
the next model is going to go ahead and
we're going to do dent so we have model
equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
where we did the imports oops there we
go our cross
this is it right here here's our
importing a dense model and here's our
importing an lstm now just about every
tensorflow model uses dents
your dense model is your basic
forward propagation reverse propagation
error
where it does reverse propagation to
program the model
so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that
luxon says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what kind of models do you have
available and so for that let's go to
the cross website
which is the cross dot io
if you go under api
layers and i always have to do a search
just search for cross api layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your activation
so a lot of your layers you can switch
how it activates uh relu which is like
your smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu
your sigmoid all the way up to soft mac
soft plus all these different choices as
far as how those
are set up and what we want to do is we
want to go ahead and if you scroll down
here you'll see your core layers and
here is your dense layer
so you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer
this is your your kind of your one set
up on there that's most common
uh convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing uh image categorizing so trying to
find objects in a picture that kind of
thing
we have pooling layers so as you have
the layers come together
usually bring them down into
a single layer although you can still do
like global max pulling 3d and there is
just i mean this list just goes on and
on there's all kinds of different things
hidden in here as far as what you can do
and it changes you know you go in here
and you just have to do a search for
what you're looking for
and figure out what's going to work best
for you
as far as which project you're working
on uh long short term memory is a big
one because this is when we start
talking about text
what if someone says the what comes
after the
the cat and the hat a little kid's book
there um it starts programming it and so
you really want to know not only um
what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is
now once we've built all our different
you know we built our model we've added
our different layers we went in there
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they branch out and
come back together if you do a uh
the sub
setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model uh as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things so we're
going to go ahead and compile
your model this brings everything
together we're going to put in what the
loss is which will use the mean squared
error
and we'll go ahead and use the atom
optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh
scikit from python
you'll recognize we have to then fit the
model
so what are we doing in here we're going
to send in our train x our train y
we're going to decide how many epics
we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this i'm
guessing it'd probably be about 200 or
300 probably do just fine
our batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it
if you're in data analytics
you might try know what this number is
as a data scientist where i haven't had
the phd level math that says this is why
you want to use this particular batch
size you kind of play with this number a
little bit
you can dig deeper into the math
see how it affects the results depending
on what you're doing
and there's a number of other settings
on here we did verbose 2. i'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbose means i think that's actually
the default on there if i remember
correctly uh there's a lot of different
settings when you go to fit it the big
ones are your epic and your batch size
those are what we're looking for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times
through all the data so if you have a
huge data set this is the point where
you're kind of wondering oh my gosh is
this going to finish tomorrow
if i'm running this on a single machine
and i have a tera terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and i'm
running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500 iterations uh
but yeah a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week
um you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will prail
the process on there more across
multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error of 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 0.08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
you know if you're retraining the stuff
over and over again it's kind of good to
know where that
error zone is so you don't have to do
all the extra processing of course if
you're going to build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it
so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set
and our test set or the
we have the
train x and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test x and our test y going in there
so we can test to see how good it did
and when we come in here we have
you'll see right here we go ahead and do
our train predict equals
model predict train x
and test predict model predict test x
why would we want to run the prediction
on train x well it's not 100 on its
prediction we know it has a certain
amount of error and we want to compare
the error we have on what we programmed
it with with the error we get when we
run it on new data that's never seen the
model has never seen before and one of
the things we can do we go ahead and
invert the predictions
this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and np
exponential m1 the train predict
and then train y equals the exponential
m1 for train y and then we do the again
that with train test predict and test y
um
again reformatting the data so that we
can it all matches and then we want to
go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score uh which is
your math square root times the mean
square root error train
y and train predict and again we're just
this is just feeding the data through so
we can compare it and the same thing
with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really
the code makes sense if you're going
through it line by line you can see
we're doing but the answer really helps
to zoom in
so we have a train score which is 2.40
of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing
when you're going out and quoting you're
publishing this you're saying hey how
good is my model it's the test score
that you're showing people this is what
it did on my test data that the model
had never seen before this is how good
my model is
and a lot of times you actually want to
put together like a little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
um test prediction standard deviation of
data set 3.16 is less than 4.4
i'd have to go back
and we're
up here if you remember we did the
square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
uh and along with
putting a formal print out of there
we want to go ahead and plot what's
going on
uh and this we just want to pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when i walk into a meeting and i'm
dealing with a number of people
they really don't want these numbers
they don't want to say hey what's i mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are
you might be dealing with a number of
different departments head of cells
might not work with standard deviation
or have any idea what that really means
number wise and so at this point we
really want to put it in a graph so we
have something to display and with
displaying you remember that we're
looking at the data
today going into it and what's going to
happen tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
uh np empty like data set uh train
predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um
the
data groups as we like them
and then putting the data in there is
what's going on here uh so we have our
train predict plot
uh which is going to be our look back
our length
plus look back
we're just is going to equal train uh
train predict
so we're creating this basically we're
taking this and we're dumping the train
predict into it so now we have our nice
train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
i put it in here double no it's just a
yeah they put it in here double
didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because
this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets
uh test
predict plot length prediction set up on
there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a time axis
always nice to have your time set on
there
set that to the time array
time axes lap
all this is setting up the time variable
for the bottom and then we have a lot of
stuff going on here as far as setting up
our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here
our main plot we have two different
plots going on here
the ispu going up and the data and the
ispu here with all these different
settings on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot i mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure plt
or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there
and so we take
and if you
go through the code piece by piece
which we're not going to do we're going
to do the
the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set we're going to
plot the train predict plot that's what
we just created
we're going to make that orange and
we'll label it train prediction
test predicts plot we're going to make
that red and label it test prediction
and so forth um set our ticks up this
actually just put ticks time axes gets
its ticks
the little little marks there going
along the axes that kind of thing and
let's take a look and see what these
graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output you say hey this is
what we're looking at
um here's our original data in blue
here's our training prediction
you can see that it trains pretty close
to what the data is up there
i would also probably put a
like a little little time stamp and do
just right before and right after where
we go from uh train to test prediction
and you can see with the test prediction
the data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set look like behind it
and how it differs
and then we can just isolate that here
on the right that's all this is
is just the
test prediction on the right uh and it's
you know there's you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing but as far as the actual test
prediction it's pretty does pretty good
it's pretty right on you can get a good
idea what to expect for your ispu
and so from this we would probably
publish it and say hey this is
what you expect and this is our area of
this is a range of error that's the kind
of thing i put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
cells are going to be this or maybe a
weekly
so you kind of get a nice you kind of
flatten the
data coming out and you say hey this is
what we're looking at the big takeaway
from this is that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces
all the tensorflows
and that is to build this sequential
model and we're only putting in the two
layers this can get pretty complicated
if you get too complicated it never
it never verges into a usable model
so if you have like 30 different layers
in here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing
so don't go too hay wire on that and
that you kind of learn as you go again
it's domain knowledge
and also starting to understand all
these different layers and what they
mean
the data
analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional will come in and say this
is what we want to try
but i tell you as a data scientist
a lot of these basic setups are common
and i don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if i only did a tangent h
instead of a relu activation
i worked for two weeks to figure that
out well the data science i can run it
through the model in you know five
minutes instead of spending two weeks
doing the the math behind it
so that's one of the advantages of data
scientist is we do it from programming
side and a data analytics is going to
look for it how does it work in math
and this is really the core right here
of tensorflow and cross is being able to
build your data model quickly and
efficiently and of course uh with any
data science
putting out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders again we want to take and
reduce the information down to something
people can look at and say oh that's
what's going on they can see stuff
what's going on as far as the dates and
the change in the ispu
now let's talk a little bit about
recurrent neural networks so neural
networks are of different types we have
cnn we have rnn a n and so on now rnn is
one type of neural network rnn stands
for recurrent neural network the
networks like cnn and a n are feed
forward network which means that the
information pretty much only goes from
left to right or from front to back
whichever way you call it whereas in
case of recurrent neural network there
will be some information traveling
backwards as well so that is why it is
known as recurrent neural network and
each of these types have a specific
application so for example convolutional
neural networks or cnn are very good for
doing image processing and
object detection using for video and
images whereas recurrent neural networks
are pretty good for doing nlp or speech
recognition and so on okay so for the
next few minutes we will kind of focus
on recurrent neural networks and we will
see an example of how we can use rnn to
do a time series analysis so in a
typical neural network this is how it
looks right so where you have a neuron
and then the inputs are coming to the
neuron and then you have an output which
goes to other neurons in the other
layers in case of recurrent neural
network what happens is you have the
inputs let's say at a given point in
time but then a part of the previous
output also gets fed in along with the
inputs for the given time now this can
be a little confusing so let's see if we
can take a little expanded view of this
so this is another view of one single
neuron which is what is known as in an
unfolded manner okay so if we are
getting inputs or data over a period of
time then this is how the neuron will
look remember these are not three
neurons this is one neuron and it is
what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are on we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus 1 an input of x t minus 1 is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of y t minus 1 then the next instant
which is x t at a time t right there is
an input of x t and then there is an
output of y t so this is a single neuron
but it's displayed in an unfolded weight
so this is like expanding it over a
period of time so let's start with this
part here this particular neuron gets an
input at at an instant t minus 1 let's
say time is equal to t minus 1 it gets
an input of x t minus 1 and it gives an
output of y t minus then when we go to
the instant t here it gets an input of x
t and it also additionally gets an input
from this previous time frame t minus 1.
so this y t minus 1 gets fed here and
that results in y t all right then when
we go to the time t plus 1 there is an
input of x t minus 1 at that given time
plus the input from the previous time
frame which is a time frame of t that
also gets fed in here and then we get an
output of y t plus one okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron so these are not three different
neurons a single neuron seen over a
period of time from t minus one to t
plus one and unlike a regular feed
forward neuron which only gets x in this
case the input is x and also another
input which is coming from the previous
time frame and that is what this loop is
in this on the left hand side diagram
this loop is indicating that okay so on
the right hand side it is represented in
an unfolded way okay so the input if we
take a time frame t for example is not
only x t which is the input which is the
normal input at the time frame t but it
is also getting an input from the
previous time frame which is this yt
minus 1 which is also being fed as an
input that is the key differentiator
here okay similarly at the instant t
plus 1 it is getting a normal input of x
t plus 1 plus this y t is actually being
fed here and then the output comes as yt
plus one okay so this is the construct
of a recurrent neural network now
recurrent neural networks again can be
of different subtypes it can be one to
one one too many many to one and many
too many depending on what kind of
application we want to use one of the
examples is like the stock price so
you're feeding so there is only one
input only thing is it is spread over a
period of time so you're feeding the
stock price input that is what comes
here as an input and you get an output
which is again the stock price which is
probably predicted over the next uh two
days or three days or ten days or
whatever so the number of outputs and
inputs is the same there is only one
input there is only one output only
thing is it is spread over a time so
variables are not many then you have one
to many so there is one input but you
are expecting multiple outputs what is
an example of this let's say you want to
caption an image so how do you want to
do that what is the input that will go
here is just an image which is one input
but what is output you're looking for
you're looking for a phrase maybe right
not just a word but a phrase so it's
like cat is sitting on a map right so
the images there is only one image which
consists of the cat sitting on a mat but
the output are like maybe three or four
words which is saying the cat is sitting
on a mat so this is one too many right
then you can have many to one examples
of this are like you're feeding some
text and you want to know the output
whether the text is what kind of
sentiment is expressed by the text it
could be positive it could be negative
so that's the output you're looking for
so you feed a large number of words
maybe the text may consist of words or
lines or whatever so that is what is the
multiple inputs but the output all it
says is the sentiment is positive so it
is just one output or the sentiment is
negative just one output right so this
is many to one then we have many too
many so what is an example of this let's
say you want to do some translation so
how do you do a translation you feed in
a sentence maybe in a particular
language english and then you want
another a sentence actually in another
language so that is like there are
multiple inputs one sentence can consist
of multiple words and the output also is
a sentence consisting of multiple words
all right so how do we implement rnn
this is an example of implementing an
rnn for a particular use case so in our
particular example we have the data
about milk production over a few months
and using rnn we want to predict because
this is time series analysis so rnn is
good to do time series analysis so using
rnn we want to predict what will be the
milk production in the future so let us
see how we can do that i will first take
you through quickly through the slides
and then i will actually run this in in
a jupyter notebook the code i will run
it in the jupyter network so this is how
it looks the code looks so while this is
tensorflow you still use the standard
python libraries like numpy and pandas
and even matplotlib to do some initial
processing getting the data processing
it cleaning it whatever all that can be
still done in within the same program so
that's what we're doing here we're
importing some libraries like numpy and
pandas and then we read the data file
and if we plot the data we see here it
is the data for for the years 1962 to 75
and we can see that there is a certain
trend right so this is how a typical
time series data would look again some
of you if you are not familiar with time
series and time series analysis and so
on i would recommend you to go through
some videos around that which will make
it easy to understand this so this is
our typical time series data would look
in this case it is nothing but there is
only one variable which is milk
production and it is spread across
several years so this is going from 1962
to 75 and that value has been plotted so
if you see there is a certain kind of a
trend here which is basically going
upwards and there will be some
seasonality so time series data has
these three components right so it will
have a trend it will have a seasonality
it will have seasonality and then it
will have some randomness so that's what
this graph is showing and
now if we want to perform analysis on
this time series analysis on this first
thing we need to do is split the data
into train and test and in this case we
will just use a straightforward method
which is taking the data for the first
13 years so the idea here is we need to
train our model right this is time
series data so what and we want to
predict for the future so the way we
need to use this is we have to take the
data for a certain period of time and
train our model and then we use a part
of the known data so that we can then
ask our model to predict for that
duration and compare it with the known
information so what do we mean by that
so here if you see this data i will show
you in the notebook as well jupyter
notebook as well this has 13 years of
data so what we are doing is we are
taking the first 12 years and using that
as our training set right so 12 years we
are doing and this has about i think 14
years of data so we are taking 13 years
of data for training purpose and then we
are using the last one year remaining
one year of data for testing purpose
because here what we can do is this one
year data we know the values right
because if we want to compare the
accuracy or anything like that we need
to know the value so in this case we
know the values of this one particular
year so we will use that but at the same
time we train the model for 13 years of
data and for the 14th year we will ask
our model to predict and then compare it
with this known value so that we know
how accurate our model is i hope that
makes sense okay so that's what we are
doing here 156 is nothing but 12 into 13
on a monthly basis we get the data the
next step is to scale the data this is
all regular data manipulation data
munching activity and then you split it
you're basically assigning the train and
test data to the to the scaled variables
and then you need to read the data in
batches so
it is very important as i mentioned
earlier also that instead of reading the
entire data in one shot you feed the
data in batches so in order to do that
we are writing a function for that
that's all we are doing here so that is
still here what we have done is regular
python programming there is no
tensorflow as of now here okay so so far
what we have done is preparation data
preparation data munching now what we
are doing is actually training our model
so this is where tensorflow now comes
into picture so we are importing first
step is to import the tensorflow library
so this is how you do it import
tensorflow as tf and then you can define
some variables or constants whichever
way now here of course there are a
couple of ways of doing it you can
create them as tensorflow nodes but that
is a little bit of an overhead we will
just use the regular python
variables are constant so here i am
creating regular python variables and i
am saying number of inputs is one so
instead of hard coding i am just storing
them as variables so this is number of
inputs is one number of time steps is 12
number of neurons is hundred and so on
right and then learning rate is 0.03 and
number of iterations we are saying is 4
000. then we create placeholders now we
will be storing the independent
variables in x and the dependent
variables in y and this we will read
from an external file remember i told
you placeholders are used for getting
data from outside and then feeding it to
our model so that's the reason we have
two placeholders one for reading the x
values and another for reading the y
values in this step we are only just
creating the nodes right so this is just
creating the graph and similarly we are
mentioning what is the loss function and
what is optimizer and how to run the
optimizer and once that is done you are
initializing the variables and then
you're creating a saver variable or a
saver instance so saver is basically
nothing but in machine learning you can
train your model and you can save it for
later use so that's where this saving
comes into play we will see how to use
that as well and then the last step is
to create your session and run this
graph right so
we are initializing the variables
remember this we run init so which is
nothing but this one so we are
initializing the variables whatever are
there instead of hard coding remember in
earlier case we were hardcoding how many
iterations so here we are saying for the
given number of iterations which are
stored in this maybe how many iterations
we said is what is the value of
iterations this is training iterations
is four thousand so we specify that
based on the number of training
iterations next batch will basically
fetch the data and then we run the
session we are basically saying train is
the node which we will run in the
session and this will basically train
our model and this is more for printing
every hundred times you print it that's
all this there's nothing more to it so
for example the output would look
somewhat like this this is for 0 this
400 next for 200 and so okay and then
you save the model you remember saver we
created so you save the model for later
use so this is our test data remember we
are doing this on training data right so
once the training data training is done
we then try to create the inference on
the test data so that we can compare how
accurate this is right so this is how
the test set would look and
then we will basically restore this
model okay because in the previous slide
we created the model and we stored it so
now we have to restore the model and
then run our test data against it and
see what are the values that are
predicted what are the y values and then
compare with x to see the accuracy so
train seed is what we are seeing here so
that is what will have the predicted
values and
these predicted values what we want to
do is we want to create an additional
column because remember we need to
compare because we want to find out the
accuracy of this model so we need to
compare the predicted values with the
actual value so what we are doing here
is adding another column called
generator and
assign a value to that all right so this
is the result of the prediction and then
if we need to reshape because we have to
show this in the form of a monthly
results so that's what we're doing here
and
once we generate the results and then
display it we can actually see it
month-wise here and
the actual and the generated values okay
so we create a data frame which is a
combination of the actual values and the
predicted values from the test set and
then we can plot to see how the trend is
as you can see pretty much the actual
value is in blue color and generated or
predicted value the curve is in yellow
color the trend is maintained so it will
probably it's not 100 accurate but the
trend is maintained all right so let's
do one thing let's go into the jupiter
notebook and take a look at how this
works in tensorflow environment actually
the code i will walk you through the
code this is my jupyter notebook and
the data is taken from this particular
link in case you're interested you can
download it from there and this is the
data for the years
1962-75 the first thing we do is import
these libraries because before we start
with the actual tensorflow activity we
need to prepare the data and so on so
for that you can use your regular python
libraries which are like numpy pandas
and so on so that's what we're doing
here and then we read the data using
pandas into a data frame so this is a
data frame milk is a data frame and we
will do some quick exploratory analysis
just to see how our data is looking
initials five records that we'll get one
two three four five that is ahead so it
goes from 1960 to january to 1960 to may
once we reach or basically we need to
split this into month specifically
separately so that's what we are doing
here date to time so we kind of do a
little bit of reindexing and then if we
plot this this is how the data look as
you can see there is a clear upward
trend and
there is some seasonality and so on but
anyway we will not break that up into
those components we will just use rnn to
predict and test okay so the next thing
is to check some if we can do run like
info it will tell us what is the
information about this data set so let
us just run that okay so it is just
telling us how many total columns and
what is the size of the file and so on
and so forth again in case you're
interested in doing some exploratory
analysis so what we'll do next is we
will take the 13 years of data for our
training data set so what are we going
to do now let me step back so what have
we seen here we have seen that there are
168 records so which is nothing but 14
years of data we now have to split this
into our training and test data set so
how do we do that i think in case of
time series we cannot do it like 80 20
like we do in normal splitting in normal
machine learning process here it is time
series data so what we are going to do
is we will take out of this 14 years we
will take the first 13 years of data and
we will use that for training and then
we will test it with the last which is
the 14th year data we will use it for
testing okay so that's what we're going
to do here so let's uh split that so
training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data i am taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use our scaling
rather we will use min max scala and we
will just scale the data and now we do
it for both test as well as train now we
are ready to create our rnn model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called next
batch and
how you want to fetch the steps they are
all defined as our constants if you
remember and that's what this function
is all about so we define that function
we will be calling that in our training
method all right so from here onwards up
to there we are done with the
preparation of the data and whatever
functions or whatever are required from
here onwards is where the tensorflow
part starts so the first thing we do is
import the tensorflow library typically
this is a very standard way of importing
the library we say import tensorflow as
tf now tf is nothing but a name so you
can change it to tf1 or abc or xyz
whatever so this part you can change but
by and large everybody uses this so we i
would rather recommend you also use the
same syntax so you say import tensorflow
stf so it's very easy for others to
understand as well and then you declare
or define a bunch of constants that's
what we are doing here like for example
the number of time steps in this case it
is 12 number of neurons there are 100
number of outputs it is only one and so
on right and then the learning rate and
all that we are declaring or defining
those variables in this particular block
next is to create placeholders you
remember the placeholders are used for
feeding the data so we have x and y x is
for the input which is the independent
variable and y is the output which is
the dependent variable and in our case
these are not different characteristics
or features but it is the same one
feature or one variable but it is over a
period of time so that's the only
difference so that's what we are doing
here and now we need to create our
network right the neural network so in
our case we said we will create a rnn
layer now there are different ways or
different formats
we use this apis for creating our layer
so each cell will be with an output
projection wrapper there is a need for
doing that and again the details of this
we will probably do in another video
where we talk in detail about rnn so for
now we are creating a gre cell with the
wrapper and the the syntax for creating
the gru cell is like this the number of
units which we we said there should be
100 neurons what will be the activation
function in this case it is relu and
then number of outputs in our case it is
only one okay so we create the cell here
okay then we got the gru cell and then
we say what is our output which is
nothing but we get the outputs and the
states and their states and which is uh
how the way we get that is tf.nnn
dot dynamic underscore rnn so if we call
this and we pass the cell and the data
which is basically in placeholder again
remember all we are doing here is we are
creating just the nodes for the graph so
nothing is actually getting executed
from a tensorflow perspective okay all
right so once that is done now we need
to pass this calculate the outputs and
the states using the dynamic underscore
rna method and we pass the cell as a
parameter and then the x values as a
parameter and if we
run that
we will have the outputs and the states
and this is where we actually run the
training method
so
or create not really run the training
method but we create the nodes for the
training and optimizer then we have the
initialization of the variables and we
save this model we create a saver object
just to save the model because we will
then restore it and run it to do our
predictions so this is what we will do
here so that is another node and this is
where we actually create a session and
run the training okay so let's go ahead
and do that that will take a little
while because we said 4000 iterations so
we will allow it to finish we will
probably come back once the training is
completed all right so the training is
done now let's go and
run this on the test data so let's just
quickly take a look at the test data set
so this is our one year data for the
year of 1975 so
if we see this is from january february
and so on and we will pass this to our
model so what are we doing here we are
restoring the model here for example
right this is the path that we have
given when we were saving the model
let's go back once and show you let me
show you where we did the saving of the
model yes so we save the model here so
that again we will restore that and we
will use that to run it on our test data
and see how well it predicts so let's go
ahead and run this and this is just 12
records so this will not take time
remember i told you training is what
takes a lot of time the regular
inference this is called inference
doesn't take much time right so it just
depends on how much data there were only
12 records here so it was very quick but
in training what we do we pass this
multiple times there are iterations 4
000 iterations we did for example so
that takes longer and in general in
machine learning deep learning training
is what takes the maximum amount of time
all right so let's go ahead and see the
results we will in order to plot it we
will have to kind of adjust the format
of the results otherwise we will not be
able to see it in a proper way and then
we will so this is our so what we have
done is we created a data frame which
consists of the predicted value and and
the actual value so this is the data
frame so this is the actual value this
834 782 and so on this is what our model
has predicted so it may not be so easy
to see in a tabler format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and training
this tutorial is about object detection
we will walk you through a tensorflow
code using which we will do object
detection in images we will tell you
what are the libraries that are required
a little bit about the cocoa data set
and then we will show you the
implementation code itself a demo of the
code alright so let's get started so
what is the tensorflow object detection
api this is an open source framework
which is actually provided by the
tensorflow team and there are trained
models available and the sample code is
also available which we can use in order
to easily detect objects in images and
videos this is pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also with a little bit of python
programming knowledge can actually use
this api this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this library
why it is required is out of the scope
of this tutorial but we will see in the
code as we walk through some of these
libraries how and why they are used the
cocoa data set coco stands for common
objects in context so this data set
consists of 300 000 images of
90 most commonly found objects like
chairs and tables and so on and so forth
so this model has been trained or in
fact a set of models have been trained
on this data set and this is pretty good
to detect the most common objects in the
images and videos so with that let's get
into the code all right so the first
part is to import all these libraries
and this we have shown you in the slides
as well again a bunch part of this will
be for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as i said the exact
details of each and every library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe a later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and
we also need this line of code to make
sure that once we
run this object detection the labeled
images are displayed within this
notebook and many of you by now must be
familiar with this and we will import a
few utility libraries and you will see
that we will be using some of these
for visualization purpose so once the
objects are detected we need to display
the information what that object is and
then what percentage of confidence the
model has so all these details that's
the utility functions that stored here
and then the next part is to prepare the
model as i mentioned we will be using an
existing trained model
the tensorflow team has actually
provided these models the one that we
will be using is ssd with the mobile net
but you can actually use any one of the
ones that are listed in this url let me
just quickly take you through this url
these are a bunch of models trained
models that are readily available for
anybody to use it is open source and let
me scroll down the only thing is that if
there are some of them with the accuracy
is much higher but they take longer and
there are some where the accuracy is not
so high and they are much faster so they
are faster but the accuracy may not be
that very high so you can play around
with some of these and we in this
particular exercise or in this
particular tutorial we are using this
ssd model which is ssd mobile at
question one so that's the model that
we'll be using so in this cell we are
primarily creating a bunch of variables
with the various for example the name of
the model the path and so on and so
forth so that we will be using these
names in the next step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as
frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if i can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it
completes i have a pretty high speed
network but even then it takes some time
so that's good but this part is over now
let us see this part and yes both are
done so once that is done we need to
load some label mapping basically what
this will do is your model as you may be
aware by now if you do some
classification the model will actually
not give any output
text it will give some numbers so if
there are five classes it will say okay
this belongs to modern class one or two
or three or five and so on the numbers
now each of these will obviously the
numbers will not make any sense to the
outside world so we need to do some
small mapping so in this case let's say
one may be a chair two maybe a table
three maybe a balloon and so on so that
kind of number to text mapping we need
to do and that is what is being done in
this particular cell and then we have a
helper code which will load the image
and convert it into a numpy array so
that the number array is what gets
processed and used by the model to do
the detection part of it so that is what
this
method is all about so we will be the
later on we will be calling that
function and
next is preparation for detection so
here we are basically telling where the
images are stored and how many images or
what is the naming convention or format
of the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently i
have test underscore images as my folder
so let me go and show this to you so
this is under my object detection folder
i have another subfolder where i am
storing my images which is text
underscore images now you can rename
this folder and give some other name and
then in your code you can probably give
that particular name for the subfold
similarly the format of these files what
is the name and format of this files
here it is in a very simple format which
is the names of the files are like beach
one beach to b3 and so on so i have
taken beach as the theme so i have
images which are related to beaches so
this is beach one beach two and then
beach three a few others but we will use
these three for our demo and so that's
what i'm saying here the name of the
images will be beach something dot jpeg
which is uh jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this particular for loop
okay so that is what this is doing all
right so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is
the function here and so let me just run
that piece of code and here is basically
where we are calling this function so we
are loading this images and then we are
calling this function uh for each image
and then we are displaying this using
the matplotlib library so let's run this
it will take one image at a time and
then detect the images now the beauty is
that the same format of the code can be
used for doing object detection in a
video so we have another video for doing
object detection in a video so most of
the code out there will be reused from
here and the only thing is that instead
of reading the images from the local
storage we read the frames from the
video and there is a neat little video
reader that is available and it will be
shown in the other video and frame by
frame we read the video and then pass on
to this function and it will act as if
each of these frames is an image and
then it will do the same object
detection on the entire video so that's
in a separate video just look out for
that and actually the information about
that is
provided
in the cards the eye symbol so that's
the the video object detection in video
that's the separate tutorial all right
so now that we have all the pieces
together this the last cell is where the
whole action takes place so let's run
this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there we go so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that too with 97 accuracy which is i
think pretty good okay and then the next
image it detects
umbrella and chair there are a few other
objects but it's not able to detect it
has detector umbrella with 63 percent
accuracy or confidence rather and the
chair with 58
again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually
balloons hot air balloons but the model
thinks it is a kite which is uh probably
not that bad it sees there is something
in the sky and therefore probably it
thinks it is a kite and it detects that
with 65
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all i wanted to show you in this
particular
tutorial about object detection in
images in this video i will walk you
through the tensorflow code to perform
object detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically we are
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example numpy
we need image i o date time and pill and
so on and so forth and of course
matplotlib so we import all these
libraries and then there are a bunch of
variables which have some paths for the
files and folders so this is regular
stuff let's keep moving then we import
the matplotlib and make it inline and
a few more imports all right and then
these are some warnings we can just
ignore them so if i run this code once
again it will go away right and then
here onwards we do the model preparation
now what we're going to do is we're
going to use an existing neural network
model so we are not going to chain a new
one because that really will take a long
time and it needs a lot of computation
resources and so on and it is really not
required there are already models that
have been trained and in this case it is
the ssd with mobilenet that's the model
that we are going to use and
this model is trained to detect objects
and it is readily available as open
source so we can actually use this and
if you want to use other models there
are a few more models available so you
can click on this
link here and
let me just take you there there are few
more models but we have chosen this
particular one because this is faster it
may not be very accurate but that is one
of the faster models but on this link
you will see a lot of other models that
are readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as
frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code all right so these two
cells
we have downloaded and import the model
and then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and
you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to
text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is 5 we know
that 5 means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
use for doing object detection in images
so this is where the actual detection
starts so here this is the path for
where the images are stored so this is
here once again we are reusing the code
which we wrote for detecting objects in
an image so this is the path where the
images were stored and this is the
extension and this was done for about
two or three images so we will continue
to use this and
we go down i'll skip this section so
this is the cell where we are actually
loading the video and converting it into
frames and then using frame by frame we
are detecting the objects in the image
so in this code what we are doing
basically is there are a few lines of
code what they do is basically once they
find an object a box will be drawn
around those
each of those objects and the input file
the name of the input video file is
traffic it is the extension is mp4 and
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image i o so we can
read and write videos using that and the
video that we are going to use is
traffic.mp4 you can use any mp4 file but
in our case i picked up video which has
like car so let me just show you so this
is in this object detection folder i
have this mp4 file i'll just quickly
play this video it's a little slow yeah
okay so here we go this is the video
it's a short one relatively small video
so that for this particular demo and
what it will do is once we run our code
it will detect each of these cars and it
will annotate them as cars so in this
particular video we only have cars we
can later on see with another video i
think i have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this traffic video so let me go back so
we will be reading this frame by frame
and um you know actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic underscore annotated and
we will see the annotated video so let's
go back and run through this piece of
code and then we will come back and see
the annotated video this might take a
little while so i will pause the video
after
running this particular cell and then
come back to show you the results all
right so let's go ahead and run it so it
is running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
underscore writer dot close all right so
i'll pause and then i'll come back okay
so i will see you in a little bit all
right so now as you can see here the
processing is done the hourglass has
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original traffic.mp4 and now you have
here traffic underscore annotated mp4 so
let's go and run this and see how it
looks
you see here just got each of these cars
are getting detected let me pause and
show you so we pause here it says car 70
let us allow it to go a little further
it detects something on top what is that
truck okay so i think because of the
board on top it somehow thinks there is
a truck let's play it some more and see
if it detects anything else so this is
again a car looks like so let us yeah so
this is a car and
it has confidence level of 69 percent
okay this is again a car all right so
basically till the end it goes and
detects each and every car that is
passing by now we can quickly repeat
this process for another video let me
just show you the other video which is a
cat again there is uh this cat is not
really moving or anything but it is just
standing there staring and moving a
little slowly and
our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and uh even
when the cat moves a little bit in the
other direction it will continue to
detect and show that it is a cat okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our network detects this cat close this
here we go and i'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to
cat the extension it will automatically
pick up because it is given here and
then it will run through so very quickly
once again what it is doing is this
video reader video underscore reader has
a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
underscore reader so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you're in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell the rest of the stuff
remains the same so i will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
r classes come back i will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have get annotated dot mp4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here
let's see yes so
what is it trying to show here it's too
small not able to see but
it is trying to detect something i think
it is saying it is a car i don't know
all right okay so in this video there's
only pretty much only one object which
is the cat and uh let's wait for some
time and see if it continues to detect
it when the cat turns around and moves
as well just
in a little bit that's going to happen
and we will see there we go and in spite
of turning the other way i think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's pretty
much it i think that's the only object
that it detects in this particular video
okay so close this so that's pretty much
it in this tutorial we will take the use
case of recognizing
handwritten digits this is like a hello
world of deep learning and this is a
nice little mnist database is a nice
little database that has images of
handwritten digits nicely formatted
because very often
in deep learning and neural networks we
end up spending a lot of time in
preparing the data for training and with
mnist database we can avoid that
you already have the data in the right
format which can be directly used for
training and mnist also offers a bunch
of
built-in utility functions that we can
straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mnist database is very
popular for training purposes initially
when people want to learn about deep
learning and tensorflow this is the
database that is used and it has a
collection of 70 000 handwritten digits
and
a large part of them
are for training then you have tests
just like in any machine learning
process and then you have validation and
all of them are labeled so you have the
images and their label and these images
they look somewhat like this so they are
hand written images collected from a lot
of individuals people have these are
samples written by human beings they
have hand written these numbers these
numbers going from zero to nine so
people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mnis
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our
tensorflow is we will feed this data
especially the training data along with
the label information and the data is
basically these images are stored in the
form of the pixel information as we have
seen in one of the previous slides all
the images are nothing but these are
pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten
these pixels so instead of taking them
in a two-dimensional arrangement we just
flatten them out so for example it
starts from here it is a 28 by 28 so
there are 784 pixels so pixel number one
starts here it goes all the way up to 28
then 29 starts here and goes up to 56
and so on and the pixel number 784 is
here so we take all these pixels flatten
them out and feed them like one single
line into our neural network and this is
a what is known as a soft max layer what
it does is once it is trained it will be
able to identify
what digit this is so there are in this
output layer there are 10
neurons each signifying a digit and at
any given point of time when you feed an
image only one of these 10 neurons gets
activated
so for example if this is trained
properly and if you feed a number nine
like this
then this particular neuron gets
activated so you get an output from this
neuron let me just use
a pen or a laser to show you here okay
so you're feeding the number nine let's
say this has been trained and now if
you're feeding a number nine this will
get
activated now let's say you fade
one to the trained
network then this neuron will get
activated if you feed two this neuron
will get activated and so on i hope you
get the idea so this is one type of a
neural network or an activation function
known as soft max layer so that's what
we will be using here this is one of the
simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the jupyter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run that as well so
as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is python and the
first step is to import the tensorflow
library so
and we do this by using this line of
code saying import tensorflow as tf df
is just for convenience so you can name
give any name and
once you do this tf is tensorflow is
available as an object in the name of tf
and then you can run its methods and
accesses its attributes and so on and so
forth and mnist database is actually an
integral part of tensorflow and that's
again another reason why we as a first
step we always use this example mnist
database example so you just simply
import mnist database as well using this
line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
let me just
use a pen to show what exactly it is so
when you do this one hot true what
happens is each label is stored in the
form of an array of 10 digits and let's
say the number is
8 okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position zero this
is at position one position two and so
on and so forth let's say this is
position seven then this is position
eight that will be one because our input
is eight and again position 9 will be 0.
okay so one hot encoding this one hot
encoding true will kind of
load the data in such a way that the
labels are in such a way that only one
of the digits has a value of one and
that indicates so based on which
digit is one we know what is the label
so in this case the eighth position is
one therefore we know this sample data
the value is eight similarly if you have
a two here let's say then the labeled
information will be somewhat like this
so you have your labels so you have this
as zero the zeroth position the first
position is also zero the second
position is one because this indicates
number two and then you have third as
zero and so on okay so that is the
significance of this one hot true all
right and then we can
check how the data is uh looking by
displaying the data and as i mentioned
earlier this is pretty much in the form
of digital form like numbers so all
these are like pixel values so you will
not really see an image in this format
but there is a way to
visualize that image i will show you in
a bit and uh this tells you how many
images are there in each set so the
training there are 55 000 images in
training and in the test set there are
ten thousand and then validation there
are five thousand so all together there
are seventy thousand
images all right so let's uh move on and
we can
view the actual
image by
using the matplotlib library and this is
how you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in
grayscale so the c map is what tells in
what way we want to view it and what are
the maximum values and the minimum
values of the pixel values so these are
the max and minimum values so of the
pixel values so maximum is 1 because
this is a scaled value
so 1 means it is
white and 0 means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and then of
course you will have variables which are
your you remember these are your weights
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
700 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are
this is a a matrix
of
values for each of the neurons and so it
is like a 10 by 784 matrix because there
are 10 neurons and similarly there are
biases now remember i mentioned bias is
only one per neuron so it is not one per
input unlike the weights so therefore
there are only 10 biases because there
are only 10 neurons in this case so that
is what we are creating a variable for
biases so this is something little new
in tensorflow you will see unlike our
regular programming languages where
everything is a variable here the
variables can be of three different
types you have placeholders which are
primarily used for feeding data you have
variables which can change during the
course of computation and then a third
type which is not shown here are
constants so these are like fixed
numbers all right so in a regular
programming language you may have
everything as variables or at the most
variables and constants but in
tensorflow you have three different
types placeholders variables and
constants and then you create what is
known as a graph so tensorflow
programming consists of graphs and
tensors as i mentioned earlier so this
can be considered ultimately as a tensor
and then the graph tells how to execute
the whole implementation so that the
execution is stored in the form of a
graph and in this case what we are doing
is we are doing a multiplication
tf you remember this tf was created as a
tensorflow object here one more level
one more so tf is available here now
tensorflow has what is known as a matrix
multiplication or matmul
function so that is what is being used
here in this case so we are using the
matrix multiplication of tensorflow so
that you multiply your input values x
with w right this is what we were doing
x w plus b you're just adding b and this
is in very similar to one of the earlier
slides where we saw sigma x i wi so
that's what we are doing here matrix
multiplication is multiplying all the
input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to define what is our loss function and
what is our optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensorflow's apis so tf
dot nn softmax cross entropy with logits
is the
api that we will use and reduce mean is
what is like the mechanism whereby which
says that you reduce
the
error and optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
optimizer we discussed about this in a
couple of slides
earlier and for that you need to specify
the learning rate you remember we saw
that there was a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call
the method
minimize for that optimizer and that
will kick start the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we wanted
to run so for example in this case we
are saying thousand steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for thousand iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques
shown here so
let us
get into the code quickly and see how it
works so this is our cloud environment
now you can
set up your tensorflow environment you
can watch that if you want to install
your local environment or you can go for
other any cloud service like for example
google cloud amazon or cloud labs any of
these you can
use and
run and try the code okay so it has got
started
we will log in
all right so this is our deep learning
tutorial uh code
and this is our tensorflow environment
and so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that
the
one hot is encoding is set to true one
hot encoding right as i explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately
and if we just check what is the type of
the data so you can see that this is a
data sets python
data sets and if we
check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float32
similarly
the
number if you want to see what is the
number of
training images there are
55 000 then there are test images 10 000
and then validation images 5000 now
let's take a quick look at the data
itself visualization so we will use
matplotlib for this
and
if we take a look at the shape now shape
gives us like the dimension of the
tensors or
or the
arrays if you will so in this case the
training data set if we see the size of
the training data set using the method
shape it says there are 55 000 and
55 000 by 784 so remember the 784 is
nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28 so
that is equal to 784 so that's what it
is showing now we can take just
one
image and just see
what is the
the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can
look at the image itself the data of the
first image itself so this is how it
shows so large part of it will probably
be zeros because as you can imagine
in the image only certain areas are
written rest is
black so that's why you will mostly see
zero say that it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so
certain locations there are some values
and then other locations there are zeros
so
that is how the data is stored and
loaded
if we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image
if you want to view it this is how you
view it so you
create like do this reshape and
matplotlib has this
feature to show you these images so we
will actually use the function called
i am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately
you will be able to see the different
images now i can change the values in
this position so which image we are
looking at right so we can say
if i want to see what is there in maybe
right so
5000 has 3
similarly you can just say 5 what is in
5 as 8
what is in 50
[Music]
again 8 so basically by the way if
you're wondering how i am executing this
code shift enter
in case you are not familiar with
jupiter notebooks shift enter is how you
execute each cell individual cell and if
you want to execute the entire program
you can go here and say run all
so that is how
this code gets executed
and
here again we can check what is the
maximum value and what is the minimum
value of this pixel values as i
mentioned this is it is scaled so
therefore it is between the values lie
between one and zero now this is
where we create our model
the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create
one placeholder and we create two
variables which is for the weights and
biases these two variables are actually
matrices so
each variable has
784 by 10
actual values okay so
one for this 10 is for each neuron there
are 10 neurons and 784 is for the pixel
values inputs that are given which is 28
into 28
and the biases as i mentioned
one for each neuron so there will be 10
biases they are stored in a variable by
the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of x into w and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize
the error so let me just execute i think
this code is executed then we define
what is our the y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had x as one placeholder
and white underscore true as a second
place holder and this will have values
in the form of uh 10 digit 10 digit
arrays
and
since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the
label for that particular number all
right then we have cross entropy which
is nothing but
the
loss
loss function
and we have the optimizer we have chosen
gradient descent as our optimizer then
the training process itself so the
training process is nothing but to
minimize
the cross entropy which is again nothing
but the
loss function
so we define all of this in the form of
a graph so up to here remember what we
have done is we have not exactly
executed any tensorflow code till now we
are just preparing the graph the
execution plan that's how the tensorflow
code works so the whole structure and
format of this code will be completely
different from how we normally do
programming so even with people with
programming experience may find this a
little difficult to understand it and it
needs quite a bit of practice so you may
want to view this
video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow
because the way tensorflow programming
is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done
maybe spark programming to some extent
will be able to easily understand this
but even in spark the the programming
the code itself is pretty
straightforward behind the scenes the
execution happens slightly differently
but in tensorflow even the code has to
be written in a completely different way
so the code doesn't get executed
in the same way as you have written so
that that's something you need to
understand and a little bit of practice
is needed for this
so so far what we have done up to here
is creating the variables and feeding
the variables and
rather not feeding but setting up the
variables and
the graph that's all defining maybe the
what kind of a network you want to use
for example we want to use a softmax and
so on so you have
created the variables how to load the
data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tensorflow now
the next step is the execution intensive
law so the first step for doing any
execution in tensorflow is to initialize
the variables so anytime you have any
variables defined in your code you have
to run this piece of code always so you
need to basically create what is known
as a node for initializing so this is a
node you still are not yet executing
anything here you just created a node
for the initialization
so let us go ahead and create that
and
here onwards is where you will actually
execute your code
in tensorflow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensorflow session so tf.session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a with loop so you have uh with
tf dot session as says and with a
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and
this session is valid
till
this block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf dot session as says you say says
dot run init now says dot run will
execute
a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying says dot run says is
basically an instance of the session
right so here we are saying tf.session
so an instance of the session gets
created and we are calling that says and
then we run
a node within that
one of the nodes in the graph so one of
the nodes here is init
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any
variables in your code in our case we
have w is a variable and b is a variable
so any variables that we created you
have to run this code you have to run
the initialization of these variables
otherwise you will get an error okay so
that is the that's what this is doing
then
we within this width block we specify a
for loop
and we are saying
we want the system to iterate for a
thousand steps and perform the training
that's what this for loop does
run training for thousand iterations
and what it is doing basically is it is
fetching
the data or these images remember there
are about 50 000 images but it cannot
get all the images in one shot because
it will take up a lot of memory and
performance issues will be there so this
is a very common way of performing deep
learning training you always do in
batches so we have maybe 50 000 images
but you always do it in batches of 100
or maybe 500 depending on the size of
your system and so on and so forth so in
this case we are saying okay get me 100
images at a time and get me only the
training images remember we use only the
training data for training purpose and
then we use test data for test purpose
you must be familiar with machine
learning so you must be aware of this
but in case you are not in machine
learning also not this is not specific
to deep learning but in machine learning
in general you have what is known as
training data set and test data set your
available data typically you will be
splitting into two parts and using the
training data set for training purpose
and then to see how well the model has
been trained you use the test data set
to check or test the validity or the
accuracy of the model so that's what we
are doing here and you observe here that
we are actually calling an mnist
function here so we are saying mnist
train dot next batch
right so this is the advantage of using
mnist database because they have
provided some very nice helper functions
which are readily available otherwise
this activity itself we would have had
to write a piece of code to fetch this
data in batches that itself is a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using mnist database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
x and the labels into y and then you
use this
batch of hundred images and you run the
training so says dot run basically what
we are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously they
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the w's and b's
get updated
till it reaches thousand iterations in
this case
the exit criteria is thousand but you
can also specify probably accuracy rate
or something like that for the as an
exit criteria so here it is it just says
that okay this particular image was
wrongly predicted so you need to update
your weights and biases that's the
feedback given to each neuron and that
is run for 1000 iterations and typically
by the end of this thousand iterations
the model would have learned to
recognize these handwritten images
obviously it will not be 100 accurate
okay so once that is done
after so this happens for 1000
iterations once that is done
you then test the accuracy of these
models by using the test data set right
so this is what we are trying to do here
the code may appear a little complicated
because if you're seeing this for the
first time you need to understand uh the
various methods of tensorflow and so on
but it is basically comparing the output
with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and you're trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not tf dot equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is
calculated as well so this is the
accuracy and that is what we are trying
to see how accurate the model is in
predicting these numbers or these digits
okay so let us run this this entire
thing is in one cell so we will have to
just run it in one shot it may take a
little while let us see
and
not bad so it has finished the thousand
iterations and what we see here as an
output is the accuracy so we see that
the accuracy of this model
is around 91 percent okay now which is
pretty good for such a short exercise
within such a short time we got 90
percent accuracy however in real life
this is probably not sufficient so there
are other ways in to increase the
accuracy we will see probably in some of
the later tutorials how to improve this
accuracy how to change maybe the hyper
parameters like number of neurons or
number of layers and so on and so forth
and so that this accuracy can be
increased beyond 90 percent thank you
all for watching this video tutorial on
the tensorflow full course i hope you
liked it if you have any questions then
please put them in the comments section
our team will help you solve your
queries thanks again stay tuned for more
from simply learn